I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on the office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of the office and give exclusive behind the scene stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're the office ladies. Hello! Hi. We're recording in the afternoon, so I was wondering what you might say, because it's not morning,
我是珍娜·费舍（Jenna Fischer），我是安吉拉·金西（Angela Kinsey）。我们一起演过《办公室》，而且我们是最好的朋友。现在，我们专门为你带来了终极的《办公室》重播播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有亲历者才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室辣妈。你好！嗨。我们在下午录音，所以我在想你会说些什么，因为现在不是早上，
and you always say, good morning. It's true. It's true. This is a very rare occasion for us. It is. I actually want to start off by saying, thank you, and I might get emotional right at the top. But I had a medical emergency with my mom and I flew back home to Texas and I just want you guys out there to know that Jenna and Cassie and Sam and everyone at
而你总是说，早上好。是真的。是真的。这对我们来说是一个非常罕见的时刻。确实。我其实想先说一句，谢谢，我可能一上来就会情绪激动。但我妈妈突发医疗紧急情况，我飞回了德克萨斯老家，我只想让你们知道，珍娜、卡茜（Cassie）、萨姆（Sam）以及
office ladies pod and ear wolf just let me I just left I just dropped everything and left you did and there everything and left. You did. And we were fine. And there were no questions. You guys were just like, get home to your mom. And it just meant so much to me to have that support that I could do that and I could go there and be with her. And everything's okay.
“办公室辣妈”播客和 Earwolf 的所有人，都让我……我直接就走了，放下一切就走了，你确实这么做了。一切都放下然后离开了。你确实这么做了。而且我们一切都好。没有任何疑问。你们大家只是说，快回你妈妈身边去。能得到这种支持让我能够做到这一点，能够去那里陪伴她，这对我意义重大。而且一切都好。
Now it was a scary few days, but I'm just so thankful for you, Jenna. And I'm so thankful that we get to do this podcast because family comes first. Well, Angela, I think I speak for everyone when I say that it was our pleasure to make that space for you. And we're so glad that you were able to be there with her because family does come first.
现在，那几天确实挺吓人的，但我真的太感激你了，珍娜。我也非常感谢我们能做这个播客，因为家庭永远是第一位的。嗯，安吉拉，我想我可以代表所有人说，为你腾出这个空间是我们的荣幸。我们很高兴你能去那里陪伴她，因为家庭确实是第一位的。
Yes. And we're recording in the afternoon, so I could have an extended time with her. Yeah. And what are we talking about? Well, today, I'm so out of it. We are talking about last day in Florida. Oh, right. Yes.
是的。而且我们在下午录音，所以我可以有更多的时间和她在一起。是的。我们在聊什么呢？哦，今天，我整个人都不在状态。我们在聊《在佛罗里达的最后一天》。哦，对的。是的。
It is season 8, episode 18, written by Robert Padnick and directed by Matt Zone. And here's your summary. As their time in Florida comes to a close, Jim tries to warn Dwight about Robert California's secret plan to sandbag the Saber store and fire him. Meanwhile, Darryl and Toby compete to sell Girl Scout cookies.
这是第八季第十八集，由罗伯特·帕德尼克（Robert Padnick）编剧，马特·佐恩（Matt Sohn）导演。以下是剧情梗介：随着他们在佛罗里达的日子接近尾声，吉姆试图警告德怀特，关于罗伯特·加利福尼亚（Robert California）企图暗中破坏萨贝尔（Saber）商店并解雇他的秘密计划。与此同时，达里尔（Darryl）和托比（Toby）竞争售卖女童子军饼干。
And Aaron decides to stay in Florida and be Irene's live and helper. I love almost every single thing Irene has to say. She's wonderful. She's so great. Her deliveries are great. I wanted Irene to come back to Dundrumiflin. That would be perfect.
而艾琳决定留在佛罗里达做艾琳（Irene）的住家助手。我喜欢艾琳说的几乎每一句话。她太棒了。她太厉害了。她的台词交付太棒了。我真希望艾琳能回到邓德米夫林（Dunder Mifflin）。那就完美了。
But this was an episode that had three very distinct story lines in three different locations. So we had to kind of keep toggling back and forth between all these different places. That's fact number one, James Spader, aka Robert California is back. Mm-hmm. You guys might remember that we shared early on
但这一集有三个非常鲜明的故事线，发生在三个不同的地点。所以我们必须在所有这些不同的地方之间来回切换。这是第一事实，詹姆斯·斯派德（James Spader），也就是罗伯特·加利福尼亚回来了。嗯哼。大家可能还记得我们早期分享过
when James Spader was contemplating whether or not he wanted to join our show, that he had this opportunity to shoot the movie Lincoln. And he said, I will come, I will do a full season of your show, but you must give me time off to go do this movie Lincoln. Right, that's where he was. That's where he's been, why we haven't seen him in a while.
当詹姆斯·斯派德正在考虑是否要加入我们的剧集时，他得到了一个拍摄电影《林肯》的机会。他说，我会来，我会拍你们的一整季节目，但你们必须给我放假去拍这部电影《林肯》。没错，他就是去那儿了。这就是他去的地方，也是为什么我们有一段时间没见到他的原因。
And so Lincoln wrapped. And now here we are. And we also shot this episode in January 2012. It was right after our holiday break. Everyone was back. Everyone was, I guess, rested and excited to get back to work. So if you think maybe we have a little more pep in our step in this episode, it's because we'd all come back from our holiday break. We were arrested, right? All right, fast fact number two, guess what else was happening at this time? Well, I know, because I went in my digital clutter. Yes, you shared the other week that Greg Daniels congratulated us on our SIG Award nomination, and now here it was
然后《林肯》杀青了。现在我们就在这里了。我们也是在 2012 年 1 月拍摄这一集的。那正好在我们假期休息之后。大家都回来了。每个人都，我猜，休息好了，并且很兴奋能回到工作中。所以如果你觉得我们在这一集里可能更有活力一点，那是因为我们都从假期休息中回来了。我们休息好了，对吧？好吧，趣味事实第二弹，你猜猜这个时候还在发生什么？嗯，我知道，因为我翻看了我的数码杂物。对的，你上周分享过格雷格·丹尼尔斯（Greg Daniels）祝贺我们获得美国演员工会奖（SAG Award）提名，现在正是
time to go. This was our fifth time attending the psych awards. We had been nominated as a cast every year since 2007. And this one was a particularly memorable one for me because I was four months postpartum. And I was really nervous about getting on a red carpet. I hadn't done that yet, hadn't had to stand in front of a bank of photographers in my postpartum-ness.
去的时候。这是我们第五次参加工会奖。自 2007 年以来，我们每年都作为演员阵容获得提名。对我来说，这次是一个特别难忘的经历，因为我当时产后四个月。我真的很紧张要走红毯。我以前还没这么做过，还没在我的产后状态下站在一排摄影师面前。
And remember, I told you about the coat closet where they let me pump. And I brought my pump with me and I pumped at the Sag Awards. Woo-woo! I remember walking down the red carpet and they asked me who I was wearing. So I did a little bit that my handbag was my pump.
并且还记得我跟你说过那个他们让我挤奶的衣帽间吗？我把吸奶器带上了，我在工会奖上挤奶了。呜呼！我记得走在红毯上时，他们问我穿的是哪个设计师的衣服。所以我开玩笑说我的手包就是我的吸奶器。
If you see pictures of me from this red carpet, you can tell I need to pump. I am falling out of my dress. Yes, a little bit. I thought you looked so radiant and beautiful and I loved the color of your dress. Oh, thank you, lady. I was so nervous.
如果你看到我这次走红毯的照片，你就能看出我需要挤奶。我都快从裙子里掉出来了。是的，有一点。我觉得你看上去光彩照人，非常漂亮，而且我很喜欢你礼服的颜色。哦，谢谢你，亲爱的。我当时太紧张了。
And this designer, Max Azria Atelier, offered to make me a custom gown. Like, designed it for my postpartum body, because I don't know if people know, but when you borrow a dress, they have something called sample sizes. Yeah. Sample sizes are very, very small.
这位设计师，Max Azria Atelier，主动提出为我定制一件礼服。就像是为我的产后身材设计的，因为我不知道人们知不知道，当你借礼服时，他们有一种东西叫做样品尺码（sample sizes）。是的。样品尺码非常非常小。
And oftentimes, even before I had had a baby, I couldn't fit into sample sizes. Also, sample sizes don't fit short people. So there's that. But sometimes they would be able to like take out the seams a little bit on the sample sizes and I could get myself into one. But I had a hard time borrowing a dress and this designer made me one from scratch. And oh my gosh, I remember getting there.
而且通常情况下，甚至在我生孩子之前，我都塞不进样品尺码里。另外，样品尺码也不适合矮个子。所以就是这样。但有时他们可以把样品尺码的缝线稍微放宽一点，我还能把自己塞进去一件。但我很难借到裙子，而这位设计师为我从头定制了一件。哦天哪，我记得到了那里。
I remember running into John and Emily. I remember running into John and Emily. I remember running into you, running into Brian. You all were so kind to me. And you just like held me up and gave me all this confidence. It was absolutely amazing. And lady, I remember what you wore to this. Oh yeah, I wore a vintage dress. It looked like old Hollywood Grecian.
我记得遇到了约翰（John）和艾米莉（Emily）。我记得遇到了约翰和艾米莉。我记得遇到了你，遇到了布莱恩。你们对我都太好了。你们就像是托住了我，给了我所有的信心。这绝对是太棒了。亲爱的，我还记得你当时穿的是什么。哦，对，我穿了一件复古长裙。它看起来像是老好莱坞希腊风。
It was light blue. The way you did your hair was kind of like this nod to old Hollywood, I felt like it was so gorgeous. It was a great look. Thanks, it was true vintage. I'd never done that before. And I did the soft waves. I was going really hard for like LA confidential.
它是浅蓝色的。你做发型的方式有点像是在向老好莱坞致敬，我觉得它太华丽了。这是一个很棒的造型。谢谢，那是真正的复古货。我以前从未那样做过。我做了柔和的波浪卷。我当时真的全力在模仿像《洛城机密》那样的风格。
Yes, yes. That's kind of what it seemed like. Well, we had a great night that night. We had so much fun. So much fun. I sat next to BJ and I was really hungry. And you know, there's not a ton of food. And BJ gave me all of his breadsticks.
是的，是的。看起来确实是那样。好吧，那天晚上我们度过了一个美好的夜晚。我们玩得太开心了。太开心了。我和 BJ 坐在一起，我当时真的很饿。你知道，那里没有太多食物。然后 BJ 把他所有的面包棍都给了我。
And I'll never forget it. Why do I think I remember this? And then guess what else I did? I will always get my words just a little bit off, you know, and my mom in there with you My mom does this like my mom will say have you seen office? It's not the office, right? And basically I'm turning into my mom in this way So at that time the president of NBC was Bob Greenblatt and he had been a big champion of this new show. Yes Yeah, no, don't say the name. Don't say the name.
我永远不会忘记。为什么我觉得我记得这个？然后你猜我还有什么举动？我总是会把我的话稍微说错一点，你知道的，我妈妈也在那儿，我妈妈就会这样，我妈妈会说，你看过《办公室》吗？不是《Office》，对吧？基本上我在这方面正在变成我妈妈。所以当时 NBC 的总裁是鲍勃·格林布拉特（Bob Greenblatt），他一直是这部新剧的大力支持者。是的。是的，别说名字。别说名字。
Okay. Debra messing with the lead. It was about Broadway. I had watched the pilot episode and I liked it. And I said to him, hey, I love smashed. And he said, thanks, it's smashed. And I was like, uh-huh. So, smashed is like a whole other. Smash just like a whole other show.
好吧。黛博拉·梅辛（Debra Messing）主演。那是关于百老汇的。我看过试播集，我很喜欢。我对他说，嘿，我喜欢《Smash（名声大噪）》。他说，谢谢，是《Smash》。我说，呃——huh。所以，《Smash》就像是完全另一个……《Smash》就像是完全另一部剧。
That's a whole other show. It's a bunch of broken 20 year old. Is anyone there? I haven't been on another NBC show. The president was like, get rid of that idiot. And then the other thing I remember from this night is, you know, we're at these really long tables. And BJ and I were at one end sort of towards the stage, and way at the other end, by this walkway,
那是另一部剧。那是一群破碎的 20 岁年轻人。有人在吗？我没上过别的 NBC 剧。当时总裁的表情就像是：把那个白痴弄走。然后我从那天晚上记起的另一件事是，你知道，我们坐在那些非常长的桌子旁。我和 BJ 在一端，靠近舞台，而在另一端，靠近那个通道的地方，
is where John was sitting. And we had these oversized bottles of wine that they set on the table. Yeah, you know, like the big, big bottles. Yeah, they like went up to like your thigh and sit on the ground. Yeah, they were kind of like decorative, but yet you could open them and drink them.
是约翰坐的地方。桌上摆着那种超大瓶的葡萄酒。是的，你知道的，就像那种很大很大的瓶子。对，它们一直高到你的大腿，就放在地上。是的，它们有点像装饰品，但你确实可以打开它们喝。
So John, his side of the table had an open theirs yet. And Matt Damon walked by and said, hi to John and Emily and they were chatting and then he turned to all of us and he goes, hey, are you not drinking this wine? And we're like, oh, and he goes, can I take it? We're like, sure. So, Matt Damon took our giant oversized bottle of wine. Oh my gosh, that's amazing. Well, I do know that I didn't stay out too late after this one, so I don't really know what happened after the awards. I had a good time at the awards, but I was tired and I knew my baby was going to be up early in the morning, so I went to bed, but I went to bed really happy until the next morning when I woke up. And I found that I had been placed on like every worst dress list there could be.
所以约翰他们那一端桌子的人还没打开他们的。然后马特·达蒙（Matt Damon）走过来，向约翰和艾米莉打招呼，他们聊了一会儿，然后他转过身对我们所有人说，嘿，你们不喝这酒吗？我们就像是，哦，然后他说，我可以拿走吗？我们说，当然。所以，马特·达蒙拿走了我们那个巨大的超大号红酒瓶。哦天哪，太棒了。好吧，我确实知道那天晚上我没有在外呆得太晚，所以我真的不知道颁奖典礼后发生了什么。我在颁奖典礼上玩得很开心，但我很累，而且我知道我的宝宝一大早就会醒，所以我去睡觉了，但我睡得非常香甜，直到第二天早上醒来。我发现自己被列入了能想到的每一个最差着装榜单上。
And this was... Seriously? Yes, this was the year that the woman wrote her like worst dress list. And she said that she knew that I only gave birth about four months ago, but like seriously, I couldn't look better than I did. Oh my gosh, so tacky.
而这……说真的？是的，就是那一年，那个女人写了她那个最差着装榜单。她说她知道我大约四个月前刚生完孩子，但说真的，我本可以看起来更好一些。哦天哪，太俗气了。
So tacky. I don't think we should have worst dress list period. Why are we commenting negatively on people's appearance? We are adults now, right? Like, have we not learned anything? I know. Get rid of worst dressed lists. Nobody cares.
太俗气了。我觉得我们根本就不该有什么最差着装榜。为什么我们要对别人的外表进行负面评论？我们现在是成年人了好吗？就像是，我们什么都没学到吗？我知道。废掉最差着装榜吧。根本没人关心。
No, they suck. They suck. They suck. They suck. They suck. They suck. They suck. They suck. They suck. They suck. They suck. They suck. They suck. They suck. They suck. They suck. They suck. They suck. They suck. They suck. They suck. They suck. They suck. They suck. They suck. They suck. They suck. They suck. They suck. They suck. They suck. They suck. They suck. They suck. They suck. They suck. They suck. They suck. They suck. They suck. They suck. They suck. They suck. They suck. They suck. They suck. They suck. They suck. They suck. They suck. They suck. They suck. They suck. They suck. They suck. They suck. They suck. They suck. They suck. They suck. They suck. They suck. They suck. They suck. They suck. They suck. They suck. They suck. They suck. They suck. They suck. They suck. They suck.. They suck. They name. Don't think I have forgotten. I know, I know, Aria Stark. All right, well, moving on to fast-pack number three. Have you heard of a blog called Ask a Manager? No. OK, it's run by this woman named Allison Green.
不，它们烂透了。它们烂透了。它们烂透了。它们烂透了。它们烂透了。它们烂透了。它们烂透了。它们烂透了。它们烂透了。它们烂透了。它们烂透了。它们烂透了。它们烂透了。它们烂透了。它们烂透了。它们烂透了。它们烂透了。它们烂透了。它们烂透了。它们烂透了。它们烂透了。它们烂透了。它们烂透了。它们烂透了。它们烂透了。它们烂透了。它们烂透了。它们烂透了。它们烂透了。它们烂透了。它们烂透了。它们烂透了。它们烂透了。它们烂透了。它们烂透了。它们烂透了。它们烂透了。它们烂透了。它们烂透了。它们烂透了。它们烂透了。它们烂透了。它们烂透了。它们烂透了。它们烂透了。它们烂透了。它们烂透了。它们烂透了。它们烂透了。它们烂透了。它们烂透了。它们烂透了。它们烂透了。它们烂透了。它们烂透了。它们烂透了。它们烂透了。它们烂透了。它们烂透了。它们烂透了。它们烂透了。它们烂透了。它们烂透了。它们烂透了。它们烂透了。它们烂透了。它们烂透了。它们烂透了。它们烂透了。它们烂透了。它们烂透了。它们烂透了。它们烂透了。它们烂透了。它们烂透了。它们烂透了。它们烂透了。它们烂透了。它们烂透了。它们烂透了。它们烂透了。它们烂透了。它们烂透了。它们烂透了。它们烂透了。它们烂透了。它们烂透了。它们烂透了。它们烂透了。它们烂透了。它们烂透了。它们烂透了。名字。别以为我忘了。我知道，我知道，艾莉亚·史塔克（Arya Stark）。好吧，接下来进入趣味事实第三弹。你听说过一个叫“问经理”（Ask a Manager）的博客吗？没有。好吧，它是由一个叫艾莉森·格林（Alison Green）的女人运营的。
She's a manager. OK. And she answers questions, like business questions, business advice questions about everything from hiring, firing, promoting, managing, everything. And I thought, you know, last week, we answered people's questions on our podcast. Yeah, we did.
她是一位经理。好的。她回答问题，比如商业问题、关于从招聘、解雇、晋升、管理到方方面面的商业咨询问题。我想，你知道，上周我们在播客里回答了听众的问题。是的，我们回答了。
Dear office ladies. Dear office ladies. I wondered what Allison would think of the advice we gave. Did you ask her? I didn't. I wondered what Allison would think of the advice we gave. Did you ask her? I didn't type it in. No, I didn't ask her. But I was pointed to her blog because an office fan named James G
亲爱的办公室辣妈。亲爱的办公室辣妈。我想知道艾莉森会对我们给出的建议作何感想。你问她了吗？我没有。我想知道艾莉森会对我们给出的建议作何感想。你问她了吗？我没打字发给她。不，我没问她。但有人向我推荐了她的博客，因为一个名叫詹姆斯·G（James G）的《办公室》粉丝
from Olympia Washington wrote in to Allison and asked a kind of cheeky question, okay? Here's what the letter said, how many employees can a workplace have before it needs a dedicated HR person? If say you had a branch location of a mid-sized paper company with 20 people combined in the office and a warehouse,
来自华盛顿州奥林匹亚，给艾莉森写信问了一个有点厚脸皮的问题，好吗？信里是这样说的：一个工作场所需要多少名员工，才需要一个专职的人力资源（HR）人员？比如说，如果你有一个中型造纸公司的分公司，办公室和仓库加起来一共 20 人，
would you need a dedicated HR person on site? Hmm. So clearly, it's an office man. Mm-hmm. Asking her if Toby needs to be in the office? Yes. So, Alison said, you don't generally need a dedicated HR person
你需要在现场配备一个专职的人力资源人员吗？嗯。所以很明显，这是一个《办公室》迷。嗯哼。在问她托比是否需要呆在办公室里？是的。所以，艾莉森说，通常情况下，直到你达到
until you hit more like 50 employees. Hmm. And a lot of companies don't bring one on until they're closer to 100. Alison said, you do need someone to handle things like payroll, Hmm. And a lot of companies don't bring one on until they're closer to 100. Allison said, you do need someone to handle things like payroll, benefits, administration, but in a small business, that's usually more of a clerk position than someone who would be doing higher level HR work, like legal compliance or investigations, or management coaching.
差不多 50 名员工之前，你都不需要一个专职的人力资源人员。嗯。而且很多公司的员工人数接近 100 人时才会配备。艾莉森说，你确实需要有人来处理诸如薪资、福利管理之类的事情，但在小企业里，这通常更像是一个文员岗位，而不是去做更高级别人力资源工作的人，比如法律合规、调查或管理教练。
Isn't that interesting? And the role of an HR person might be management coaching, which is why Michael hated Toby so much. But this was my favorite part, Ellison went on to say, but if you're asking about Toby on the office, it was never clear to me why he was there. There you go.
是不是很有趣？而人力资源人员的角色可能是管理教练，这就是为什么迈克尔那么讨厌托比。但这是我最喜欢的部分，艾莉森接着说，但是如果你问的是《办公室》里的托比，我从来没搞懂他为什么会在那里。给你说中了。
I mean, add that to also three accountants and also a temp who went to Florida and a receptionist that went to Florida. Plus they hired Ryan back after he pretty much after he's embezzled from the company. So someone in hiring isn't making super great choices. Well, James, maybe you can write to Allison Ne and ask her of a midsize paper company with 20 employees needs three accountants. We'll see what she said. Yeah. Well, that's all I got lady. Well, I have a little something to share. A while back, I was trading emails with Robert Padnick. And as you know, he wrote this episode. And I asked him about it and he said it was a really challenging point in the season because there were so
我的意思是，再加上三个会计，还有一个去了佛罗里达的临时工，以及一个去了佛罗里达的前台。另外他们还把瑞安重新招了回来，尽管他基本上从公司挪用了公款。所以招聘部门的某个人做出的选择真的不怎么样。好吧，詹姆斯，也许你可以写信给艾莉森，问问她一个拥有 20 名员工的中型造纸公司是否需要三个会计。我们看看她怎么说。好的。好吧，我只有这些了，亲爱的。好吧，我有一点小东西要分享。前段时间，我和罗伯特·帕德尼克通过邮件交流过。如你所知，他写了这一集。我向他问起这件事，他说这是这一季中一个非常具有挑战性的节点，因为有
many characters and plots to juggle, especially with all of the Florida storylines. And he shared with me a few moments that stand out and I'm gonna sprinkle them throughout the episode. Oh great. And he also shared with me some of his very first outlines and there was a Pam storyline that he had in his outline that didn't make it.
这么多的角色和情节需要兼顾，尤其是所有佛罗里达的故事线。他跟我分享了几个脱颖而出的时刻，我会在这一集里穿插讲述。哦太棒了。他还跟我分享了他最初的一些大纲，在大纲中有一个帕姆的故事线最终没有被采用。
And I want to share that with you too. This is going to be a good episode. Yeah. All right, we'll take a break and be right back. Well, the episode's gonna start Andy gets off the phone and he comes out to the bullpen to share terrible news that Dwight is no longer with us. And everyone was like, what happened? And Andy's like, well, he took the job in Florida. He's gonna be the VP.
我也想把它分享给你。这一集会很精彩。是的。好吧，我们休息一下，马上回来。好吧，这一集从安迪接完电话开始，他来到办公区分享了一个可怕的消息：德怀特已经离我们而去了。大家都问，发生了什么？安迪说，嗯，他在佛罗里达找到工作了。他要当副总裁了。
And Angela's like, you implied that something horrible had happened to him. And he goes, yes, he had a stroke, a massive stroke of good luck. Yes. And now he's in a better place. Well, this makes everyone wonder if they can open up his treasure. Yes, he left behind a treasure chest. Yeah, he did. Who would be insane enough to open it? Yeah, not sure. Maybe the guy that grows muck beans in his drawer. Maybe.
安吉拉说，你刚才暗示他出了什么可怕的事故。安迪说，对啊，他中风了，交了桃花运（巨幅好运）。是的。现在他在一个更好的地方了。嗯，这让大家都想知道他们能不能打开他的宝藏。是的，他留下了一个宝箱。是的，他确实留下了。谁会疯到去打开它呢？嗯，说不准。也许是在抽屉里种豆芽的那个人吧。也许吧。
Oscar has a talking head that says, when the team left for Tallahassee, Dwight told everyone not to touch his treasure. Obviously, he wants us to obsess about it. There's nothing in there. Which is obviously what he would want us to think, making it the perfect place to hide a treasure. Oh, God, I'm Wallace Sean in the Princess Bride. Mm-hmm.
奥斯卡有一段面对镜头的独白说：当团队出发去塔拉哈西时，德怀特告诉所有人不要碰他的宝藏。很显然，他是想让我们对此念念不忘。里面什么也没有。而这显然是他想要我们去想的，这使它成为藏宝的绝佳地点。哦，天哪，我是《公主新娘》里的华莱士·肖恩（Wallace Shawn）。嗯哼。
I loved that talking head. Lady, I have something in common with Oscar. What? I also portrayed Wallace Sean. Oh, yes, I remember this. Here's a fun fact for you guys. During the pandemic, Jason Wrightman, who, as you guys all know, has directed several office episodes, reached out to Brian Oscar and myself to be part of
我太喜欢那段独白了。亲爱的，我和奥斯卡有一个共同点。什么？我也扮演过华莱士·肖恩。哦，对，我记得这个。这里有个好玩的趣事要告诉大家。在大流行期间，杰森·雷特曼（Jason Reitman）——正如大家所知，他导演过好几集《办公室》——联系了布莱恩、奥斯卡和我，让我们参与
a Princess bride reenactment to raise money for World Central Kitchen. Basically, everyone got a few lines. He reached out to a whole bunch of actors, and you just delivered your line at home. Your family member would like film you with a cell phone. I wore my son's Shakespeare costume that he used in fifth grade for his English project. And then Jason took all this footage and put it all together to sort of play out the whole movie, but it was really sweet and very homemade. And the great thing is it raised a million dollars for World Central Kitchen. Wow. And for those of you who aren't familiar with World Central Kitchen, kitchen. Wow. And for those of you who aren't familiar with World Central Kitchen, it is a charity that was started by Chef Jose Andres, and they
《公主新娘》的重现拍摄，为“世界中央厨房”（World Central Kitchen）筹集资金。基本上，每个人只有几句台词。他联系了一大群演员，你只需要在家念你的台词就行。你的家人会用手机帮你拍摄。我穿了我儿子五年级做英语项目时穿过的莎士比亚服装。然后杰森把所有这些素材剪辑到一起，差不多演出了整部电影，但这真的很温馨，而且非常自制。最棒的是，它为“世界中央厨房”筹集了一百万美元。哇。对于那些不熟悉“世界中央厨房”的人来说，它是一个由何塞·安德烈斯（Jose Andres）主厨创立的慈善机构，他们会
immediately take meals to people in need, whether it be from a natural disaster or humanitarian crisis, and they feed people when they need it most. I remember they were some of the first people on the ground in Ukraine. Yep. They showed up in Maui after the fires. Yes, if there's anywhere that's been hit with a hurricane or anything, they are there. I think they've served something like almost 300 million meals to people in need.
立即将热乎的饭菜送到有需要的人手中，无论是因为自然灾害还是人道主义危机，他们在人们最需要的时候为他们提供食物。我记得他们是第一批抵达乌克兰现场的人之一。没错。火灾发生后他们出现在了毛伊岛。是的，如果有什么地方遭受了飓风或其他打击，他们就会出现在那里。我想他们已经为有需要的人提供近 3 亿份餐食了。
Wow. So it's a pretty amazing organization. I follow them on Instagram because I just like to see where they are in the world helping people. I actually have our clip, me and Brian and Oscar. Oscar is playing Enigo Montoya. Brian is playing Fesick, and I am playing Vizini. Here's the clip.
哇。所以这是一个相当了不起的组织。我一直在 Instagram 上关注他们，因为我只想看看他们在世界的哪个角落帮助人们。我其实有我们的片段，我和布莱恩还有奥斯卡。奥斯卡扮演伊尼戈·蒙托亚（Inigo Montoya）。布莱恩扮演费西克（Fezzik），我扮演维兹尼（Vizzini）。这就是那个片段。
He has very good arms. He didn't fall! Inconceivable! You keep using that word. I do not think it means what you think it means. That's it. Oh my gosh, I love all the extra sound effects. I know.
他胳膊练得很好。他没掉下去！难以置信！你一直在用这个词。我觉得它并不是你想的那个意思。就是这样。哦天哪，我喜欢所有的额外音效。我知道。
Now, were you pretending like you were looking over the side of a cliff? Yes. But really, I was just standing on a ladder on the side of my house and we tried to find a tree that looked like shrubbery or something. Oh my gosh, that's pretty cool. Well, now, Andy is standing in front of a whiteboard. They're clearly having a conversation
现在，你当时是在假装自己正看着悬崖边吗？对。但实际上，我只是站在我家房子外面的梯子上，我们试图找一棵看起来像灌木丛之类的树。哦天哪，太酷了。好了，现在，安迪站在一块白板前。他们显然在讨论
as to whether or not they should open the treasure and what the treasure might hold. I wish we could have seen more of this conversation because people have been making suggestions. Look at that dry erase board behind Andy. Here are a few shrewt bones, star-washed stuff, nudie mags, rosebud type scenario, photos with our toothbrushes up his butt, actual gold trap. These are everyone's theories. They're not bad theories. They're really not. Although I might change Star Wars stuff to Battle Star Galactic. Yeah. Well, everyone decides Creed should open the box. And when he does, it's a photo
是否应该打开宝藏，以及宝藏里可能会有什么。真希望我们能看到更多这段对话，因为大家一直在提议。看安迪身后的那块干擦白板。这里有一些精辟的见解：星战周边、色情杂志、玫瑰花蕾类型的场景、把我们的牙刷插在他屁股上的照片、真正的金陷阱。这些是大家的理论。这些理论不赖。真的不赖。虽然我可能会把星战周边改成《太空堡垒卡拉狄加》。是的。好吧，大家都决定让克里德（Creed）来开箱。当他打开时，里面是一张
of everybody. Yeah, a really nice photo. And then a dart flies up, almost hitting Creed and goes into the ceiling. We had a fan question from Lily R in El Salvador who said, please tell us the story behind that photo. You all look so happy and out of character, especially rain and Angela and Mindy are holding hands. It's really cute. I zoomed in on the picture, Lily, and then I also asked Steve Berges, what is this picture? Was it on the call sheets for the week? Did we have to take it?
所有人的合影。是的，一张非常好看的照片。然后一支飞镖飞了出来，差点击中克里德，射进了天花板。我们收到了来自萨尔瓦多的莉莉·R（Lily R）的粉丝提问，她说，请告诉我们那张照片背后的故事。你们看起来都那么开心，而且和平时在剧里的性格不太一样，特别是雷恩（Rainn）和安吉拉，曼迪（Mindy）还手拉着手。真的好可爱。莉莉，我把照片放大看了，然后我还问了史蒂夫·伯吉斯（Steve Burgess），这张照片是什么？它在当周的通告单（call sheet）上吗？我们必须拍这个吗？
And he said, no, there was nothing on the call sheets. He thinks Phil just found some random photo we had taken as a cast one day. Maybe it was someone's birthday. We have no idea. He wasn't sure. But we don't look in character for sure. We're not in character, but we're all in costume.
他说，没有，通告单上什么都没有。他觉得菲尔只是找了一张我们作为演员阵容在某天拍的随意的照片。也许是谁的生日。我们不知道。他也不确定。但我们看起来确实不像剧中的角色。我们不在角色状态里，但我们都穿着戏服。
Yeah. Yeah, I wonder if it was a photo that we took on set for the new season. I wish I had it. I really like it. It's really cute. Dwight is going to have a talking head now where he's like, are you kidding me? Who would put a poison dart? Not that he knows for sure that it was a poisonist dart.
对。是的，我在想这会不会是我们为新季在片场拍的一张照片。我真希望我有这张照片。我真的很喜欢它。真的很可爱。德怀特接下来会有一段面对镜头的独白，大概是：开什么玩笑？谁会放毒镖？倒不是说他确切知道那就是毒镖。
But they probably shouldn't have been opening someone's treasure chest. I want to point out a lovely bird of paradise behind Dwight during this talking head. No. So. All right, so this episode starts on the golf course. Dwight, Nellie, Jim, and Robert, California are playing around a golf. Cringe Fest. Oh, God.
但他们大概本来就不该去开别人的宝箱。我想指出德怀特在这次独白时身后的一株漂亮的“天堂鸟”花。没有。所以。好吧，所以这一集从高尔夫球场开始。德怀特、奈莉（Nellie）、吉姆和罗伯特·加利福尼亚正在打高尔夫球。尴尬盛宴。哦，天哪。
So cringy. Well, Robert just loves the chemistry between Dwight and Nelly. And Nelly is thrilled that they're going to be working alongside one another. I mean, they're a regular archipald and George. Not a real English duo. Not a real English duo. No, she says. No, no.
太尴尬了。好吧，罗伯特非常喜欢德怀特和奈莉之间的化学反应。奈莉对他们将并肩工作感到非常兴奋。我的意思是，他们简直是标准的阿奇博尔德（Archibald）和乔治（George）。根本不是什么英国双人组。根本不是什么英国双人组。不，她说。不，不。
She really made Robert look like the goat of Dover. Goat of Dova. Also, not real. Made up. Mm-hmm. I decided to Google some famous English duos, okay? And I thought, why don't I throw some names at you and you tell me if you think they're real or fake?
她真的把罗伯特衬托得像个多佛山羊（goat of Dover）。多佛山羊。同样，不是真的。是编出来的。嗯哼。我决定谷歌一下一些著名的英国双人组，好吗？我想，为什么我不抛出一些名字，然后你来告诉我，你觉得它们是真的还是假的？
So you've mixed in some fake ones with real ones. Correct. Okay. Cannon and ball. Real or phony? Real. Yes! Max and Doony? Real. Yes! Max and Dolly.
所以你把一些假的混进真的里面了？没。好的。坎农和鲍尔（Cannon and Ball）。真的还是假的？真的。耶！马克斯和杜尼（Max and Doony）？真的。耶！马克斯和多莉（Max and Dolly）。
Fake. Yes! Oh my gosh. Thompson and Grover. Fake. Yes! Oh my goodness. I am, you're good.
假的。耶！哦天哪。汤普森和格罗弗（Thompson and Grover）。假的。耶！哦天哪。我……你真厉害。
I'm trying, here's what I'm doing that thing where you like play the player. I'm trying to think of how you would position real or fake. Okay. Flanders and Swan. Real. Yes. Murray and Mooney. Fake.
我在尝试，我是这么做的，就像你在玩那个玩家游戏一样。我在想你会如何判断真假。好的。弗兰德斯和斯旺（Flanders and Swan）。真的。对。默里和穆尼（Murray and Mooney）。假的。
Real. Jervace and Merchant. Real. Yes. There's your quiz. Okay. You really made me look like the goat of Doe over there. Thought I was gonna be able to trick ya.
真的。杰维斯和莫昌特（Jervace and Merchant）。真的。对。这就是你的小测验。好吧。你真的把我衬托得像个多佛山羊了。还以为我能把你套进去呢。
Dwight is really, what's that expression? I had an uncle you say, he's really showing his ass. You know, like he's being an idiot. Oh yeah. He's showing his ass, he's celebrating too soon. Oh yes, we have this conversation when we watch football all the time. Don't celebrate too soon.
德怀特真的——那个表达怎么说来着？我有个叔叔常说，他真是“在自曝其丑（showing his ass）”。你知道的，就像他在当个白痴。哦，对。他在自曝其丑，他庆祝得太早了。哦，对，我们看橄榄球时经常有这种对话。不要庆祝得太早。
It's not a touchdown till it's a touchdown. That's right. Anyway, he's really being annoying. And Jim's like everyone chipped in, got you a gift, you know, since you're going to be staying here in Florida. He wax it with the golf club. Doesn't open it. Doesn't open it.
在触地得分之前那还不算触地。没错。不管怎样，他真的很讨人厌。吉姆就像是：大家凑钱给你买了个礼物，你知道的，既然你要留在佛罗里达了。他用高尔夫球杆拍了拍它。没打开。没打开。
Yeah, we had a fan question from Kate F. in Austin, Texas, who said, what was the gift that Dwight teed off on the golf course? Kate, the script never said. I have a guess. What do you think it was? A watch. It seemed watch-sized.
是的，我们收到了来自得克萨斯州奥斯汀的凯特·F（Kate F.）的粉丝提问，她说，德怀特在高尔夫球场上开球打飞的那个礼物到底是什么？凯特，剧本里从来没写过。我有个猜你觉得是什么？一块手表。看起来像手表的大小。
Feels like a gift to you give people at work. Like, congrats. Thanks, here's your watch. It could have been a prank. But it's not sincere. No, it did. Jim has a talking head where he says, it's not. No. It's not seer. Jim has a talking head where he says it's a word-filling knowing that this is the last time he's ever gonna see Dwight. Mm-hmm.
感觉像是你在工作时送别人的礼物。就像是，祝贺。谢谢，这是你的手表。也可能是一个恶作剧。但它不是真心的。不，确实。吉姆有一段面对镜头的独白，说这并不是……不。这不是……吉姆面对镜头说，知道这是他最后一次见到德怀特，这种感觉有些言语难以形容。嗯哼。
It's not better sweet. Yeah, what is it? What's the word? Sweet. Yeah. Well, Darrell's gonna enter Andy's office. He's taking his Girl Scout cookie orders for Jada. Yeah. Andy's down for a box or whatever. You know, just whatever you choose, Darryl.
这不是苦乐参半。对，那是什么？是什么词？甜。好吧。好吧，达里尔要走进安迪的办公室了。他在收为杰达（Jada）买的女童子军饼干订单。是的。安迪打算订一盒还是什么的。你知道的，随便你选哪个，达里尔。
So Darryl chooses tree foils and Andy groans. He's clearly disappointed. Why did he let Darryl choose? I know. I have some girl scout cookie stats for ya. Ooh, someone else might have gone to their website as well. What you got? Oh, well, I know what their highest selling flavor is,
所以达里尔选了“树叶饼”（Trefoils），安迪发出了一声痛苦的呻吟。他显然很失望。他为什么要让达里尔选呢？我知道。我有一些女童子军饼干的数据要告诉你。哦，看来另一个人也去了她们的网站。你有什么？哦，好吧，我知道她们全国销量最高的是什么口味，
nationally, thenments. Yes, do you know what number two is? Samoa's. Is this because you went to the website? Yes. Do you know what their least popular cookie is? I stopped there. The tree foils.
薄荷巧克力饼（Thin Mints）。是的，你知道第二名是什么吗？萨摩亚饼（Samoa's）。这是因为你去了她们的网站吗？是的。你知道她们最不受欢迎的饼干是什么吗？我在那儿停下了。树叶饼。
Oh, the shortbread. Looks like our writers are in went to the website too. I like the tree foil. I like a shortbread cookie. We writers are in went to the website too. I like the tree foil. I like a shortbread cookie. We've discussed this. I like it too. I like a tag along. Oh, tag alongs are number three.
哦，黄油酥饼（shortbread）。看来我们的编剧也去过那个网站了。我喜欢树叶饼。我喜欢黄油酥饼。我们讨论过这个。我也喜欢。我喜欢“夹心饼”（Tagalong）。哦，“夹心饼”排在第三。
Filed by adventure foals. A cookie I'd not heard of. Nope, I guess it's kind of a brownie and it has like a caramel cream thing on top. I don't know. Fifth place is dosido. That's all I got though. I have Dono 6th or 7th or anything like that. So if you want that, you're gonna have to look it up yourself. Go to the website. Yeah. Well, Tobi's gonna enter. He's doing the same thing this year.
接下来是“冒险夹心饼”（Adventure Fols）。一种我没听过的饼干。不，我猜它有点像布朗尼，上面还有某种焦糖奶油的东西。我不知道。第五名是“多西多”（Dosido）。我只有这些了。我没有第六名或第七名之类的数据。所以如果你想要那个，你得自己去查。去网站上看。嗯。好吧，托比要进来了。他今年也在做同样的事。
It's his first time ever he's taking cookie orders for his daughter Sasha. Anna Mary S from Scranton, Pennsylvania, and many others would like to play a bull shit card. Oh, let's play it. I have a catch for this episode involving the cookie storyline in this episode Toby tries to sell cookies by saying that it's Sasha's first year. However, in stress relief, Toby makes Dwight buy cookies from him in exchange for signing his apology letter.
这是他第一次为女儿萨莎（Sasha）收集饼干订单。来自宾夕法尼亚州斯克兰顿的安娜·玛丽·S（Anna Mary S）以及许多其他人想打一张“胡扯”牌。哦，我们打一张吧。我发现这一集里关于饼干故事线的一个漏洞：在这一集里，托比试图通过说这是萨莎的第一年（卖饼干）来推销饼干。然而，在《缓解压力》那一集中，托比为了让德怀特在道歉信上签字，逼德怀特向他买饼干。
Good catch. Good catch. Very good catch. But anyway, he says it's Sasha's first year. And Darrell's a little bit like, dude, this is my territory. You can't just, I've been selling cookies here for years. You can't just come in here. No.
好发现。好发现。非常棒的发现。不过不管怎样，他说这是萨莎的第一年。达里尔有点像是，老兄，这是我的地盘。你不能——我在这里卖饼干好几年了。你不能就这样闯进来。不。
They ultimately settle with this. Darryl says, you know what? You can have the whole entire office just give me accounting. Toby's like, hey, that sounds like a good deal. How did Toby not realize what Darryl was doing right away? I don't know. I mean, come on. It's Kevin.
他们最终达成了这样的妥协。达里尔说，你知道吗？你可以拥有整个办公室，只要把会计部留给我。托比就像是，嘿，听起来是个不错的交易。托比怎么没有立刻意识到达里尔在搞什么鬼？我不知道。我的意思是，拜托。那是凯文。
It's Kevin. Kevin buys more cookies than anyone else combined. That's really who you want. Well, now we're gonna check in with our third storyline of the episode, which is Erin. Yeah. She is now working for Irene, the elderly lady that she met at the store opening.
那是凯文。凯文买的饼干比其他人加起来还要多。那才是你真正想要拉拢的人。好吧，现在我们要来看看这一集的第三条故事线，也就是艾琳。是的。她现在为艾琳工作，那是她在商店开业时遇到的一位老太太。
Mm-hmm. She's been grocery shopping. Kind of running her errands, doing her odds and ends. Mm-hmm. We had a fan catch from Erin W. and Albuquerque, New Mexico, who said, I spot Harvey's supermarket bags. Aaron, so did I. Did you know that Harvey's supermarkets were established nearly a century ago by Iris and J.M. Harvey? In 1924? Yeah. And I think we read the same website again,
嗯哼。她一直在帮她买杂货。差不多是跑跑腿，做些零碎杂务。嗯哼。我们收到了来自新墨西哥州阿尔伯克基的艾琳·W（Erin W.）的粉丝提问，她说，我发现了哈维斯超市（Harvey's supermarket）的购物袋。艾琳，我也是。你知道哈维斯超市是在近一个世纪前由 Iris 和 J.M. 哈维创立的吗？在 1924 年？是的。我想我们又看了同一个网站，
because their son Joe took over in 1950. They are spread out through Florida and Georgia. Although, in August of this year, it was announced that Windixi and Harvey's were gonna be acquired by Aldi. Yeah. And so some are gonna stay Harvey's and some are gonna be Aldi's.
因为他们的儿子乔（Joe）在 1950 年接管了它。它们遍布佛罗里达州和佐治亚州。不过，在今年八月，有消息称 Winn-Dixie 和哈维斯将被阿尔迪（Aldi）收购。是的。所以有些会继续保留为哈维斯，有些会变成阿尔迪。
Yeah. Well, I'll have you know that I some are gonna be all these. Yeah. Well, I'll have you know that I texted with Phil Shea about these grocery bags. And he told me that he got the bags from Harvey's just for this scene. I love that. Also, if you zoom in on the medicine bottles, there's a montage of Aaron doing these chores for Irene.
好吧，我要告诉你的是，有些会变成阿尔迪。是的。好吧，我要告诉你的是，我曾就这些购物袋与菲尔·谢伊（Phil Shay）发过短信。他告诉我，他专门为了这个场景从哈维斯弄来了这些购物袋。我太喜欢这个了。另外，如果你放大看那些药瓶，会看到一个艾琳为艾琳做这些杂务的蒙太奇。
Yeah, the little Hill bottles, I guess. He have labels printed with Irene's name on them. Phil Shay Y'all. Phil Shay. He does not mess around. All in the details. So I have two favorite lines in this episode, and one of them is in this scene. Irene wants to introduce Aaron to her grandson, and Georgia Engle delivers this so perfectly, she says,
是的，那些小药瓶，我猜。他甚至印了带有艾琳名字的标签。菲尔·谢伊，天哪。菲尔·谢伊。他做事绝不含糊。全在细节里。所以我这一集里有两个最喜欢的台词，其中一句就在这个场景里。艾琳想把艾琳介绍给她的孙子，佐治亚·恩格尔（Georgia Engle）把这句台词交付得太完美了，她说，
when can I introduce you to my grandson? He's a wonderful swimmer. Shallow in, deep in, he does it all. I know. It's so brilliant. I thought that was so funny. Aaron says today's not gonna work because she has to tell Andy
我什么时候能把我的孙子介绍给你？他是个出色的游泳运动员。浅水区、深水区，他什么都行。我知道。太绝了。我觉得这一段太搞笑了。艾琳说今天不行，因为她必须告诉安迪
she's staying in Florida. I'm gonna play a bullsh**t card. Okay. Really? She's already left under Mifflin. She's no longer working for them. She's been living with Irene, running her errands. I don't know how many days now.
她要留在佛罗里达。我要打一张“胡扯”牌。好吧。真的吗？她已经离开邓德米夫林了。她不再为他们工作了。她一直和艾琳住在一起，帮她跑腿。我不知道现在过去多少天了。
She hasn't let anyone at the company know. She hasn't given notice. And now she's just gonna casually mention it on like a FaceTime call with Andy. This isn't how people operate in the business world. I know, but it's Erin. I know, but it's Aaron. I know, but it's true. Has this not gotten back in some official manner?
她没有让公司的任何人知道。她没有递交辞呈。现在她只是打算在和安迪的视频通话中轻描淡写地提一句。现实商业世界里的人可不是这样运作的。我知道，但她是艾琳。我知道，但她是艾琳。我知道，但事实确实如此。这难道没有通过某种官方途径传回公司吗？
Like has she not shown up for things? Right, she's just, she's just disappeared at all saber meetings and moved in with Irene. She's mentioned it to Ryan, who I guess supposedly put it in as Tumblr. You know what? I know that's an upcoming scene. And lady, I was like, what is Tumblr? And I went online.
比如她难道没有在某些场合缺席吗？没错，她只是，她只是在所有的萨贝尔会议上都消失了，然后搬去和艾琳同住。她向瑞安提起过，我猜瑞安大概把它发到 Tumblr 上了。你知道吗？我知道那是接下来的一个场景。亲爱的，我当时想，Tumblr 是什么？然后我上网查了。
I got what it was. Okay, I looked it up because I wanted to remember. I was like, oh yeah, Tumblr. Here's what they call themselves. There are cross between a social networking site and a blog often referred to as a micro blog. Is it just where you update people? I needed to learn more. I created a Tumblr account.
我搞懂那是什么了。好吧，我查了一下，因为我想记起来。我当时想，哦对，tumblr。这是他们对自己（平台）的称呼：它是社交网站和博客的结合体，通常被称为微型博客。这只是一个用来向人们更新动态的地方吗？我需要了解更多。我创建了一个 Tumblr 账号。
Stop it. Just because I needed to understand what it is more, is it photos or you just type things? It looked like a combination of Twitter and Instagram. looked like a combination of Twitter and Instagram. Okay. So like, you could write a much longer thing, but you could also put a picture. All right.
住手。就因为我需要更好地理解它是什么，它是发照片还是只打字？它看起来像是推特（Twitter）和 Instagram 的结合体。它看起来像是推特和 Instagram 的结合体。好吧。所以你可以写一篇长得多的东西，但你也可以放一张照片。好吧。
Sam, Cassie, have you guys ever tumbled? Oh yeah, I had a tumbled for a long time. Am I describing it correctly? Yeah, I'd say it's like a personal blog. But it's mini because it shows up like a scroll. Yeah, you just scroll to them. No, you're scrolling through a lot of different blogs at once like Reddit or Instagram. Okay. I don't even understand Reddit. I don't understand how you post on Reddit. I don't understand what a sub-reddit is
萨姆、卡茜，你们用过 Tumblr 吗？哦，对，我用过好长一段时间 Tumblr。我描述得准确吗？对，我会说它就像是一个个人博客。但它是迷你版的，因为它呈现出来就像是一个信息流。是的，你就在上面滚动浏览。不，你是同时在滚动浏览许多不同的博客，就像 Reddit 或 Instagram 一样。好吧。我甚至不懂 Reddit。我不懂怎么在 Reddit 上发帖。我也不懂什么是子版块（subreddit），
in compared to a regular Reddit. Do you? No. I don't understand any of it. I appreciate people out there on Reddit because you and I sometimes come across some cool information. Yeah.
跟普通的 Reddit 有什么区别。你知道吗？不知道。我什么都不懂。我很感激 Reddit 上的那些网友，因为你和我有时会从上面发现一些很酷的信息。是的。
I don't understand it. Do you have to have an account? Oh my gosh, we're a hundred. Yes, you do. Okay, and what's a sub-reddit? I actually don't know. I don't know. I did learn what LOL really means. Oh no, Ange, we didn't want to tell you. Oh yeah, everyone's been tagging me in that asking why I didn't interject like I was sitting there. Why we didn't interject and I just wanted to let you have that moment. It was touching my dad. But it's laugh out loud, but not lots of laugh.
我不懂。你必须注册一个账号吗？哦天哪，我们都一百岁了。是的，你必须注册。好吧，那什么是子版块？我其实也不知道。我不知道。我确实搞懂了 LOL 真的到底是什么意思。哦不，安吉（Ange），我们本来不想告诉你的。哦，对，每个人都在那个视频里@我，问我为什么当时不插话，就像我坐在那儿一样。为什么我们没有插话，我只是想让你拥有那一刻。那很感人，爸爸。但那是“大笑”（laugh out loud），而不是“很多笑”（lots of laugh）。
But I think you knew that, right? I think I did. I think I confused it in the moment. In the moment. But when you text me LOL, you mean laugh out loud, right? I think I just mean I'm laughing. I'm laughing real hard. LOL.
但我想你知道的，对吧？我想我是知道的。我想我当时在那个时刻把它搞混了。在那一刻。但当你给我发 LOL 的时候，你的意思是“大笑”，对吧？我想我只是指我在笑。我笑得很厉害。LOL。
LOL. LOL. LOL. LOL'm laughing real hard. L-R-H. L-R-H. L-R-H. L-R-H. L-R-H. L-R-H. Yeah. That's what I'm doing.
LOL。LOL。LOL。LOL笑得超大声。L-R-H。L-R-H。L-R-H。L-R-H。L-R-H。L-R-H。是的。我就是那个意思。
Okay. Anyway, back to this scene. Robert Padnick, our writer, shared with me that he wrote a joke for this scene that was one of his favorite ones in the episode. He said when Aaron serves Irene Boyle Gatorade, that it just was a small silly joke, but it still makes him chuckle to this day. I almost boiled some Gatorade and drank it just to see how awful it would be, but I didn't. I want you to know, I did a lot of kind of like hands-on experimentation for this episode.
好吧。不管怎样，回到这个场景。我们的编剧罗伯特·帕德尼克跟我分享说，他为这个场景写了一个笑话，这是他在这一集里最喜欢的笑话之一。他说，当艾琳给艾琳·博伊尔（Irene Boyle）端去佳得乐（Gatorade）时，这只是一个小小的、傻乎乎的笑话，但直到今天依然能让他忍俊不禁。我差点煮了一杯佳得乐然后喝下去，就为了看看它会有多难喝，但我没有。我想让你知道，为了这一集，我做了很多那种“动手实践”的实验。
I have a big one coming up that I have yet to share. But I mean, I started my own tumbler. I almost boiled Gatorade. What did you do? I'm playing the scenes in my head. Oh my gosh, what did you do? It's a big tangent. You'll have to wait for it.
我有一个重头戏要登场，但我还没分享。不过我是说，我自己注册了 Tumblr。我差点把佳得乐煮了。你都做了什么？我在脑海里回放这些场景。哦天哪，你都干了些什么？这是一个大大的题外话。你们得等会儿才知道。
I hope you like it. All right. Well now Nelly is going to get some very hands-on golf instruction from Robert. Super cringey. Super cringy. Super cringy. You know, we had a fan question from Alex F. in Larkspur, California, who said, my dad and I were watching the golf course scene, and we were very adamant to point out
84|||我希望你喜欢。好吧。现在，罗伯特将对内莉进行一些非常亲切的高尔夫指导。超级尴尬。超级尴尬。超级尴尬。你知道，我们收到了来自加利福尼亚州拉克斯珀的亚历克斯·F.的粉丝提问，他说，我和我爸爸在看高尔夫球场的场景时，我们非常坚决地指出
that that is California. It is not Florida. Do you have any idea what course they're playing on? Well, thanks to Steve Burgess. I do know what course they're playing on. Well, thanks to Steve Burgess. I do know what course they were playing on. This was Bramar Country Club, unrecitable of art in Tarzana. It is near the Balboa Sports Complex, which is where we would set up our base camp of trailers and work vehicles. I looked up the club. It's named after Bramar Scotland, which is a town known for its golfing. The club has hosted several golf tournaments like the LPGA's Women's Kemper Open, and they also have a tennis club.
那是加利福尼亚州。不是佛罗里达州。你知道他们在哪个球场拍的吗？嗯，多亏了史蒂夫·伯吉斯。我确实知道他们在哪个球场拍的。嗯，多亏了史蒂夫·伯吉斯。我确实知道他们在哪个球场拍的。这是位于塔扎纳的布拉马乡村俱乐部，艺术无从复述。它靠近巴尔博亚体育综合体，我们在那里搭建了拖车和工作车的基地营地。我查了这个俱乐部。它是以苏格兰的布拉马命名的，这是一个以高尔夫闻名的城镇。该俱乐部举办过几场高尔夫锦标赛，比如LPGA的女子肯珀公开赛，他们还有一个网球俱乐部。
Yes, they have hosted the Virginia Slims and the Davis Cup. They have a lot of different memberships. If you're interested, you can do full golf, limited golf, racket sports, or social. Full golf gets you everything. You can golf anytime. You can play tennis, pickleball, fitness. You can eat in the restaurant, whatever you want. You can swim in the pool. It's the main membership, top membership.
是的，他们举办过弗吉尼亚·斯利姆赛和戴维斯杯。他们有很多不同的会员资格。如果你感兴趣，你可以选择全高尔夫、有限高尔夫、球拍运动或社交会员。全高尔夫让你享受一切。你可以随时打高尔夫。你可以打网球、匹克球、健身。你可以在餐厅吃饭，随心所欲。你可以在游泳池游泳。这是主要的会员资格，顶级会员资格。
Is this what you did? Did you go there and try out the club? I joined the club just so I could talk about it. I'm fucking out. I was like, it seems like you I could talk about it. I was like, it seems like you learned a lot about it. I did. Did you really? It's an initiation fee of anywhere from 20,000 to 100,000
这是你做的吗？你去了那里并试用过这个俱乐部吗？我加入这个俱乐部只是为了能谈论它。我他妈的不干了。当时我想，看来你——我能谈论它。我当时想，看来你对它了解很多。我是了解。真的吗？入会费在2万到10万之间
to join, but I did it for the hot. That's insane. I charged Ear Wolf. I'm kidding. I'm kidding. It's not that. I did not join this club. But if you want to join, you can join. Like I said,
才能加入，但我这么做是为了那个热潮。太疯狂了。我记在厄尔·沃尔夫账上了。开玩笑的。开玩笑的。不是那样的。我没有加入这个俱乐部。但如果你想加入，你可以加入。就像我说的，
they don't say on the website what the fees are. I had to dig a little deeper. So that's a proximate, you know, to pay a ton to join. And then you also have to pay per year after that. Country clubs are expensive, I guess. I'm not clearly not a member of any. Me either, but that's some cha-ching, cha-ching. You know what I secretly hoped? What? I've always read about how people play golf in Florida and an alligator will just walk on the, what do you call it, field? No. Course? Golf course? Yes. Golf field. What is wrong with those? I don't know. I have had no sleep. But yeah, I thought how great would it have been in the distance if you saw an alligator? This is turning into happy Gilmore now.
他们网站上没有说明费用是多少。我不得不深入挖掘一点。所以大概，你知道的，加入要花一大笔钱。然后之后你还得每年付费。乡村俱乐部很贵，我猜。我显然不是任何俱乐部的会员。我也不是，但那可真是哗啦哗啦花钱啊。你知道我暗中希望什么吗？什么？我一直读到人们如何在佛罗里达州打高尔夫，然后就会有一只短吻鳄直接走到，你叫它什么，球场？不。球场？高尔夫球场？是的。高尔夫球场。那些人脑子怎么了？我不知道。我没睡觉。但 是的，我想如果在远处看到一只短吻鳄会有多棒？这现在变成《滑稽吉尔莫》了。
Oh my god, it is. It is an alligator and a back. An alligator walk on. Back at Dundermifland, Darrell is going to walk over to accounting. It's time to sell Kevin some cookies. Kevin has a talking head that I really feel like we need to hear. In the shooting draft script, it said, Kevin has an 80 style rap energy. Yes, this is his way of expressing his enthusiasm for the cookie season. Yeah. Oh, the springtime thinks that it's the best. In falltime thinks that it's the best.
哦，天哪，真的是。是一只短吻鳄和一背。短吻鳄走上场。回到邓德米夫林，达瑞尔要走到会计部去。是时候向凯文推销一些饼干了。凯文有一段访谈镜头，我觉得我们真的需要听听。在拍摄剧本中，上面写着，凯文有一种80年代说唱风格的能量。是的，这是他表达对饼干季热情的独特方式。是啊。哦，春季觉得它是最好的。而秋季觉得它是最好的。
Cold time has kind of a strut. And Valentine thinks that it's the best. But gather around, peeps are telling you the truth. Nothing beats the cookie season, that's the truth. He's ready. He wants his cookies. Our writer Robert shared with me that in one of his early outlines for this episode, he had written a runner for Pam and Kevin.
寒冷的时候有一种高傲的姿态。而情人节觉得它是最好的。但大家聚拢来，伙伴们在跟你说实话。没有什么比饼干季更好的了，这是实话。他准备好了。他想要他的饼干。我们的编剧罗伯特跟我分享说，在这个剧集的一个早期大纲中，他为帕姆和凯文写了一条支线。
Oh, yeah. So Pam loves thinments. They're her favorite. And Kevin overhears her ordering her two box of thinments, and he makes fun of her for liking them. He calls her an amateur. And then their storyline would have continued, but I'm gonna save the second part for later. Oh, I like this.
哦，是的。所以帕姆喜欢薄荷巧克力饼干。那是她最喜欢的。凯文无意中听到她订购了两盒薄荷巧克力饼干，他嘲笑她喜欢这种饼干。他称她为业余爱好者。然后他们的故事线本来会继续，但我要把第二部分留到以后再说。哦，我喜欢这个。
I like this little Kevin Pam thing that never happened. I know, but it was interesting to me and they sort of would have had a bonding moment which Pam and Kevin hardly ever have. Yeah, so it didn't make it in, but I love that Robert Padnik shared it with me. Well, I did love when Pam and Kevin had their moments when they did. They were rare, like you said, but you know, remember they had second breakfast?
我喜欢这个从未发生过的小小的凯文和帕姆的桥段。我知道，但这对我来说很有趣，他们本会有某种建立情感联系的时刻，而帕姆和凯文几乎从没有过。是的，所以它没有被收录进去，但我很高兴罗伯特·帕德尼克跟我分享了这一点。好吧，我很喜欢帕姆和凯文有过互动的时刻，当他们有的时候。正如你所说，它们很罕见，但你知道，还记得他们吃过第二顿早餐吗？
Yeah. And second lunch and everything. Mm-hmm. I think we should take a break because when we come back, I have a big, deep dive for you. And I hope your taste, deep dive for you. And I hope your taste buds are ready for it. It's not cookies. Did you bring girls' cookies?
是的。还有第二顿午餐什么的。嗯哼。我想我们应该休息一下，因为当我们回来时，我有一个非常深入的探讨要带给你。我希望你的味蕾——深入探讨要带给你。我希望你的味蕾已经准备好了。不是饼干。你带了女孩们的饼干吗？
Nope, it's not cookies. I know, you just said that. Right. All right, we'll are back. And Kevin is getting ready to make his cookie order. Okay. Darryl standing there, you know, and Kevin is scratching the cookie sheet and smelling it. The order sheet.
不，不是饼干。我知道，你刚才就这么说了。对。好吧，我们回来了。凯文正准备下单买饼干。好吧。达瑞尔就站在那儿，你知道的，凯文正在抓挠饼干订单表格并闻着它。订单表格。
Yeah. Yeah, remember this, and Darryl's like, it's not scratch and sniff. And Kevin's like, sometimes you can get something. Well, this small moment in this episode prompted Amy E from Nova Scotia Canada to write in. And it made my day. This is right up my alley, Amy. Amy from Nova Scotia, what's your got? Amy said said I have been waiting for this episode to share a bit of a fun deep dive that I think you'll appreciate. When Kevin is trying to scratch and sniff the cookie order form and claims, quote, you still get a little something. There is clearly a power of suggestion at work here.
是的。是的，还记得这个吗，达瑞尔说，这不是刮刮乐。凯文说，有时候你能闻到点什么。好吧，本集中的这个小插曲促使来自加拿大新斯科舍省的艾米·E.写信给我们。这让我一整天都心情大好。这完全符合我的风格，艾米。来自新斯科舍省的艾米，你有什么发现？艾米说，我一直在等待这一集播出，好分享一个有趣的深度探讨，我想你们会欣赏的。当凯文试图抓挠并闻饼干订单表格并声称，“你还是能闻到一点点”时，这里显然有一种暗示的力量在起作用。
And every time I watch this scene, I'm reminded of how the power of suggestion, when it comes to smell swept an entire nation and how it still lives on today in myth and infamy. Myth and infamy, the drama! An entire nation! Okay, let's hear it! Amy went on to explain. In 2011, Canada switched to plastic $100 bills. And shortly thereafter, dozens of people started reaching out to the Bank of Canada to ask if they had embedded a scratch and sniff on the $100 bill because they soar they noticed that their $100 bills smelled like maple syrup.
每次我看这个场景，我都会想起关于气味的暗示力量是如何席卷整个国家的，以及它如何在今天作为神话和恶名继续流传。神话与恶名，这太抓马了！整个国家！好吧，说来听听！艾米接着解释说。2011年，加拿大换发了塑料材质的100加元纸币。不久之后，几十人开始联系加拿大银行，询问他们是否在100加元纸币上嵌入了刮闻式气味，因为他们发誓他们注意到他们的100加元纸币闻起来有枫糖浆的味道。
Everyone agreed, maple syrup. Maple syrup. Word got out about this alleged maple syrup-cented money and Canadians across the whole country started reporting that they, too, smelled maple syrup in the $100 bill. Amy said as a Canadian myself. Did you bring a $100 bill from Canada? No. Oh so sorry I did not fly to Canada. Well, I don't know you can go to a bank and maybe exchange. I don't know currency anyway
每个人都同意，是枫糖浆。枫糖浆。关于这种据称带有枫糖浆香味的货币的消息传开了，整个国家的加拿大人开始报告说，他们也在这张100加元纸币上闻到了枫糖浆的味道。艾米说，作为一个加拿大人。你从加拿大带了一张100加元纸币吗？没有。哦，真抱歉，我没有飞去加拿大。好吧，我不知道你可以去银行也许兑换一下。不管怎样，我不知道货币的事情。
You didn't it's okay. I didn't I didn't I had I'm trying to guess what you did. Okay. You'll never guess It's completely unrelated to scratch and sniff sort of. Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay. You will get there. You know how I am with surprises. I can't take it. You liked your a guesser. I'm a guesser.
你没有，没关系。我没有，我没有，我有——我在猜你做了什么。好吧。你永远不会猜到。这和刮刮乐完全没有关系，差不多吧。好吧，好吧，好吧，好吧，好吧。你会猜到的。你知道我对惊喜的态度。我受不了。你喜欢当猜谜者。我是个猜谜者。
I should have just surprised you. Okay. You can set it up and now you know. Now I'm guessing. Okay. Anyway, Amy said that as a Canadian myself, I can confirm that I have tested this and I also think that the $100 bills had a hint of a maple syrup scent.
我本该直接给你个惊喜的。好吧。你可以铺垫一下，现在你知道了。现在我在猜。好吧。不管怎样，艾米说，作为一个加拿大人，我可以证实我测试过这一点，我也认为100加元纸币有一丝枫糖浆的香味。
Amy said the Bank of Canada reports that it did not include any maple syrup scent. It was not added. And a professor from McGill University who specializes in olfactory perception told ABC News that it is possible to smell a smell that's not actually there. Although it is uncommon on such a large scale, like across an entire country's population. So this professor, Dr. Marilyn Jones-Gottman, explained that olfactory illusions are typically triggered by emotional stimuli. So in this scene, Kevin, he's wrapped about these cookies, right? Like he has an emotional response, an emotional stimuli to getting his cookie sheet.
艾米说，加拿大银行报告称，它没有包含任何枫糖浆香味。没有添加这种成分。麦吉尔大学一位专门研究嗅觉感知的教授告诉美国广播公司新闻网，闻到实际上并不存在的气味是可能的。尽管在如此大的规模下，比如在整个国家的人口中，这是不常见的。所以这位教授，玛丽莲·琼斯-戈特曼博士解释说，嗅觉错觉通常是由情感刺激引发的。所以在这一幕中，凯文，他正在为这些饼干说唱，对吧？就像他对他拿到饼干表单产生了一种情感反应，一种情感刺激。
So it is possible that he would smell the cookies on this cookie sheet. I get it, I get it. Yeah. So Amy said, I hope you enjoyed this little deep dive and fun fact NPR reported on the Canadian maple syrup money phenomenon in 2013. And then did a poll asking Americans what they thought a good scent would be for the American dollar bill and the winner was the Apple pie, followed by Bacon. I just thought was really funny. Yeah. So, here's the thing. I found this so interesting that I shared it with my family one night at dinner because
所以他在这张饼干表单上闻到饼干的味道是可能的。我懂了，我懂了。是的。所以艾米说，我希望你们喜欢这个小小的深度探讨，还有一个有趣的事实：美国国家公共电台（NPR）在2013年报道了加拿大枫糖浆货币现象。然后进行了一项民意调查，询问美国人他们认为美圆钞票的好气味是什么，获胜者是苹果派，其次是培根。我只是觉得这真的很好笑。是的。所以，事情是这样的。我觉得这太有趣了，以至于有一天晚饭时我把它分享给了我的家人，因为
I do that. I share with them little tidbits that I learned by doing this podcast. And my son was like, Mom, oh my gosh, yes, this is a thing about how all of these senses work to sometimes trick you into smelling things that aren't really there or even tasting things that aren't really there. And he told me about an article in Cosmopolitan, I don't know how he came across this article
我就是这样。我跟他们分享我通过做这个播客学到的小花絮。我儿子就说，妈妈，哦，天哪，是的，关于所有这些感官如何有时会欺骗你，让你闻到实际上并不存在的东西，甚至尝到实际上并不存在的东西，确实有这么一回事。他跟我讲了一篇《时尚Cosmopolitan》杂志上的文章，我不知道他是怎么看到这篇文章的，
called the crazy thing you never knew about skittle flavors. Which is that? Was he looking up skittles? He was probably looking up skittles. Yeah. But here is what it is. Skittles come in five colors, but they all have the same taste formula. And I said no, they don't. I know that a red skittle tastes different than a yellow skittle.
叫做《你从未了解过的关于彩虹糖口味的疯狂事情》。是什么？他在查彩虹糖吗？他可能在查彩虹糖。是的。但事实是这样的。彩虹糖有五种颜色，但它们的味道配方都一样。我说不，它们不一样。我知道红色彩虹糖尝起来跟黄色彩虹糖不一样。
And he said, no. There's nothing in the color enamel. There's no taste in the color enamel. No, here's what it is. You brought a skittle. I brought you a skittles! Now you can relax. I'm gonna figure it out.
他说，不。颜色涂层里什么都没有。颜色涂层里没有味道。不，事实是这样的。你带了彩虹糖。我给你带了彩虹糖！现在你可以放松了。我会弄明白的。
Yes. Because we ended up buying skittles and doing this taste test at home. And I thought maybe we would enjoy doing it here But what it is is they do have different colors and different fragrances So it is your olfactory senses that are tricking you into thinking you are tasting something But you are not this is very interesting because a few years ago,
是的。因为我们最后买了彩虹糖并在家里做了这个味觉测试。我想也许我们会喜欢在这里做这个测试，但事实是它们确实有不同的颜色和不同的香味。所以是你的嗅觉在欺骗你，让你以为你在品尝某种东西，但你其实并没有。这非常有趣，因为几年前，
I got COVID, part of the OG strain of COVID, and my husband and I both lost our sense of taste and smell. I could cut a lemon in half, I could lick it, I could bite into it, nothing. I sort of got a message from my tongue that something was tingling, but I couldn't taste it. I bit into a hamburger, it tasted like cotton balls. We had soup, I dumped a ton of cayenne pepper, I couldn't taste it at all. My nose started to run a little. Oh, but I couldn't taste it. I mean,
我得了新冠，属于最原始毒株的那种，我和我丈夫都失去了味觉和嗅觉。我可以把一个柠檬切成两半，我可以舔它，我可以咬它，什么感觉都没有。我的舌头隐约收到了一点刺痛的信号，但我尝不出味道。我咬了一口汉堡，尝起来像棉花球。我们喝汤，我倒了大量的卡宴辣椒面，我一点也尝不出来。我的鼻子开始流了一点鼻涕。哦，但我尝不出味道。我是说，
these two things are so linked. Yeah. You're smelling your taste. And I was, it was depressing. It took all the joy out of eating and cooking because you couldn't smell anything. Well, I guess the Skittles people are using this fact to their advantage, this link between the olfactory senses and the taste. Because it's way more expensive to manufacture five different insides than it is to just put a bit of fragrance
这两者是如此紧密相连。是的。你是在用嗅觉品尝。这太让人沮丧了。这夺去了吃东西和做饭的所有乐趣，因为你什么也闻不到。好吧，我想彩虹糖的人正在利用这个事实来谋取利益，利用嗅觉和味觉之间的这种联系。因为制造五种不同的内部成分要比只添加一点香味
and a color, but the site is another part of it. I want to say, I have another study for you. There was a study done in England where this guy named Charles Spence gave a bunch of British students clear beverages and clear bottles. All the different beverages were actually flavored different flavors. He had orange, grape, apple, and lemon. And when they tasted all the beverages when they were clear, they were able to say what they were. They were like, that's lemon. That's grape, orange, got it. But then he put food coloring in them that did not correspond to the taste. Yeah, so like he put orange food coloring in the grape flavored drink and when they drank it, they said it was orange flavored. Wow. They couldn't taste the actual flavor anymore because their
和颜色昂贵得多，但视觉是另一部分。我想说，我为你准备了另一个研究。英国曾做过一项研究，一个名叫查尔斯·斯彭斯的家伙给一群英国学生发了透明瓶子里的透明饮料。所有不同的饮料实际上都调配了不同的风味。他有橙子味、葡萄味、苹果味和柠檬味。当他们品尝所有这些透明的饮料时，他们能够说出它们是什么。他们说，那是柠檬。那是葡萄，橙子，懂了。但随后他在其中加入了与味道不相符的食用色素。是的，就像他在葡萄味的饮料中加入了橙色食用色素，当他们喝下它时，他们说它是橙子味的。哇。他们再也尝不出实际的味道了，因为他们的
eyes were telling them that it was a different flavor. Interesting. Right? Yeah. All right, so are you ready? Sam, Cassie, would you all like to come in here and eat some Skittles as well? Skittles challenge. Let's see how it goes. Okay, I got my Skittles and I promise everyone
眼睛告诉他们那是另一种味道。很有趣，对吧？是的。好吧，那么你们准备好了吗？萨姆、凯西，你们都想进来吃点彩虹糖吗？彩虹糖挑战。让我们看看进展如何。好吧，我拿到了彩虹糖，我向大家保证
we will continue working down this episode after we eat some Skittles. All right, so here's how we did it. I closed my eyes and I put my hand out and then I showed what I had and then I ate it and I tried to guess, but you also have to plug your nose because here's the crazy thing.
我们吃完彩虹糖后会继续研究这一集。好吧，我们是这样做的。我闭上眼睛，伸出手，然后展示我拿到的东西，然后我吃了下去，并试图去猜，但你还得捏住鼻子，因为最疯狂的是：
When I wasn't plugging my nose, I was able to tell what flavor it was. But when I plugged my nose, they all tasted the same to me. But if I was in the middle of chewing and then I opened up my nose, I could suddenly then taste it again. Does it scent it? Because they're scented. Okay, so I'm going to give you all the same one.
当我不捏住鼻子时，我能分辨出它是什么味道。但当我捏住鼻子时，它们尝起来都一样。但如果我正嚼着，然后松开鼻子，我突然就能再次尝出味道了。这是因为它们有香味吗？因为它们有香味。好吧，我要给你们每人发一颗一样的。
Obviously. Hey, your eyes are closed, closing eyes. Okay. And we're just supposed to eat it. And now are we plugging our nose? Yes, closed, closing eyes. Okay, and we're just supposed to eat it. And now are we plugging our nose? Okay. Show everybody what it was. I don't know. Can you see it? The color they are eating is... It's harder to when you can't breathe. I'm so sorry, you can't breathe through your mouth. I'm trying. Well, I chew, but it's difficult.
很显然。嘿，闭上眼睛，闭上眼睛。好吧。我们应该直接吃掉它。现在我们要捏住鼻子吗？是的，闭上眼睛，闭上眼睛。好吧。我们应该直接吃掉它。现在我们要捏住鼻子吗？好吧。向大家展示它是什么。我不知道。你能看见吗？他们正在吃的颜色是……当你不能呼吸时，这更难。我很抱歉，你不能用嘴呼吸。我在努力。好吧，我在咀嚼，但这很难。
Okay, Sam, now did you know what it was before you unplugged your nose? Because you're still chewing your... Oh, am I supposed to unplug my nose now? Now you can try. But what did you think it was? Orange, Cassie. I thought it was green. It was orange.
好吧，萨姆，在你松开鼻子之前你知道它是什么吗？因为你还在嚼你的……哦，我现在应该松开鼻子吗？现在你可以试试了。但你觉得它是什么？橙子，卡西。我以为是绿色的。是橙子。
Oh! Very good. Very good. Would you like one more? Yes. I'm not answering to you myself. Okay. The color they've been given is so now you're chewing it. Your noses are plugged. Do you have any sense of what it is? No. No. Okay, unplug your nose. Did that help? Did you get a burst of flavor when I can't right what is it great great? Yes? Isn't that crazy? Everyone you can try it at home If you guys want to enjoy Well, I have to thank my son for that because he's the one who told me about it and we had a lot of fun
哦！非常好。非常好。你还想要一颗吗？是的。我可不替你回答。好吧。他们被分到的颜色是——所以现在你在咀嚼。你们的鼻子都捏着。你们对它是什么有任何感觉吗？没有。没有。好吧，松开鼻子。那有帮助吗？当你不能——什么？是什么？是葡萄吗？葡萄？是的？是不是很疯狂？大家可以在家里试一试，如果你们想享受的话——好吧，我得为此感谢我的儿子，因为他是那个告诉我这件事的人，我们玩得很开心
We yeah, really fun family. Yes. We love any kind of like taste test sort of experiments at home. Well, not related to that at all, but when I was home, my mom saves everything and she had my old book of stickers and there are scratch and sniffs in there and they still smelled after all these years. I mean, that's scratch and slip book is older than some people listening to this podcast. And they still smelled. I had a scratch and sniff sticker book when I was a kid two years. It's fake. We were best friends.
我们，是的，非常有趣的家庭。是的。我们在家里喜欢任何类似味觉测试的实验。好吧，和那个完全无关，但当我回家时，我妈妈什么都存着，她留着我以前的贴纸簿，里面有刮闻式贴纸，过了这么多年它们居然还有香味。我的意思是，那个刮闻式贴纸簿比听这个播客的一些人还要老。它们居然还有香味。我小时候有一本刮闻式贴纸簿，两年了。是假的。我们是好朋友。
Well, Toby is now going to realize Darryl's real plan. And he is going to be like, hey, what the heck, Darryl? Yeah, March is over to accounting. And now they start arguing over who gets to have Kevin. Darryl says, Kevin, do you want to buy cookies from me? And Kevin says, oh, I definitely do. The next two lines of dialogue were improvised the day of. They weren't in the shooting draft.
好吧，托比现在要意识到达瑞尔真正的计划了。他会说，嘿，怎么回事，达瑞尔？是的，大步走向会计部。现在他们开始争论谁能得到凯文。达瑞尔说，凯文，你想从我这买饼干吗？凯文说，哦，我当然想。接下来的两句台词是当天即兴发挥的。拍摄剧本里没有。
And when they happened, we all lost it over in accounting. It cracked us up so much, everyone loved it. They're like, you have to do it again. What was it? Craig improvised. Hit the road Jack to Toby. And then Paul is Toby improvised right back. No you hit the road Jack.
当它们发生时，我们在会计部那边全都惊呆了。这把我们逗乐惨了，大家都喜欢。他们说，你得再来一次。是什么？克雷格即兴发挥了。对托比说“滚开，杰克”（Hit the road Jack）。然后保罗饰演的托比马上即兴回敬道。不，你才滚开，杰克。
And we lost it. Well eventually Toby is going to suggest that they split the order, but Kevin says, no, I'm going to pick one of you, and I'm going to decide who it is after I've been wind dined and 69, metaphorically. Yeah. Well, Jessica N from Rochester, New York, wrote in and said, I cannot wait to hear what notes standards and practices had for Kevin saying he wanted to be wind dined and 69. They allowed it to be in there, but are they the reason that Kevin had to say the metaphorically part? I mean, I feel like Todd Packer has thrown this out there before. I feel like Todd Packer has said much worse in the. I feel like Dodd Becker has said much worse
我们都笑疯了。好吧，最终托比会提议他们平分订单，但凯文说，不，我要在你们中间选一个，而且我要在经历过风风雨雨和“69式”之后再决定是谁，隐喻意义上的。是的。好吧，来自纽约州罗切斯特的杰西卡·N.写信说，我迫不及待地想听听标准与实践部门对凯文说他想经历风风雨雨和“69式”有什么意见。他们允许它出现在剧集里，但他们是导致凯文不得不说“隐喻意义上的”这个词的原因吗？我的意思是，我觉得托德·帕克以前也说过类似的话。我觉得托德·帕克说过更糟糕的话。我觉得托德·帕克说过更糟糕的话
in the last few episodes, or at least comparable. Steve Burgess says he went back, he looked through all of the standards and practices notes for this episode. There was no mention at all of Kevin's line. What about Packer's doggie style? No mention. No mention.
在过去的几集里，或者至少是差不多的。史蒂夫·伯吉斯说他回去查看了这一集的所有标准与实践部门的修改意见。根本没有提到凯文的台词。帕克的“狗爬式”（doggie style）呢？也没提到。没提到。
I don't know. Maybe was there a change over standards and practices? Were they on vacation? I don't know. But Steve Burgess did say this line was not in the table draft. That's the one that they send to standards and practices. Oh, okay. But he said they are also required to send the network cut
我不知道。也许标准与实践部门有人事变动？他们当时在度假？我不知道。但史蒂夫·伯吉斯确实说过这句台词不在围读剧本里。那是他们发给标准与实践部门的那版。哦，好吧。但他说他们还被要求发送电视台剪辑版
and the final locked cut of the episode after we filmed it. And there were no notes on any of those either. He said, maybe they missed it or figured we'd said much worse things in the past. But Steve said he was surprised that we didn't have to fight about it. Back in Florida at the golf course, Jim and Dwight say their final goodbyes. Dwight's just really gloating. He's being really obnoxious. He raced his off in his golf cart. First one to the clubhouse wins, you know? Yes.
以及我们在拍摄完这一集之后的最终锁定剪辑版。这两版也没有任何修改意见。他说，也许他们漏掉了，或者觉得我们过去说过更糟糕的话。但史蒂夫说他很惊讶我们居然不需要为此争论。回到佛罗里达的高尔夫球场，吉姆和德怀特道别。德怀特简直是在幸灾乐祸。他表现得非常讨厌。他驾驶高尔夫球场疯狂加速。第一个到达会所的人赢了，你知道的？是的。
And Robert says to Jim, you know what, let Dwight have his fun now because I've decided to take the Sabre store. Yeah. He says, when Dwight does his presentation for the board with Nelly, he's going to reject their proposal and he's going to fire them on the spot, basically. And he said he couldn't do it sooner because Joe endorsed the idea, but it's a horrible idea, ultimately. He says, have you seen our product?
罗伯特对吉姆说，你知道吗，现在就让德怀特去开心吧，因为我决定拿下赛博（Sabre）商店了。是的。他说，当德怀特和内莉一起为董事会做演示时，他将拒绝他们的提案，并且基本上当场解雇他们。他说他不能早点这么做，因为乔赞同这个想法，但这最终是个糟糕透顶的想法。他说，你见过我们的产品吗？
We can't sell it in stores. It's a piece of crap. Yeah, people can't hold this in their hand. They've got to order it, site unseen. Yes. That's the only way we're going to sell these things. Well, we got a fan question from Alison H. and Louisville, Kentucky who said, I have a question.
我们根本不能在商店里卖。这简直是个破烂货。是的，人们根本无法把这东西拿在手里。他们必须在没见过实物的情况下盲订。是的。这是我们卖掉这些东西的唯一途径。好吧，我们收到了来自肯塔基州路易斯维尔的艾莉森·H.的粉丝提问，她说，我有一个问题。
Why did Robert, California insist on Jim coming to Florida if he knew that he was going to kill this project in the end and that any of the people tied to it would likely be fired. My conspiracy theory is that he was hoping Jim would get the VP job and he would have a reason to fire him because maybe he stole a little biter at Jim for laughing at his misery in the pool party episode. I know it's a stretch but I cannot make sense of this because overall he seems to like Jim. Listen, if his plan was to fire everyone involved
为什么罗伯特·加利福尼亚坚持要吉姆来佛罗里达，如果他明知自己最后会毁了这个项目，而且任何与之相关的人都可能被解雇的话？我的阴谋论是，他希望吉姆得到副总裁的职位，这样他就有理由解雇他，因为也许他在池塘派对那一集里因嘲笑他的悲惨遭遇而对吉姆怀恨在心。我知道这有点牵强，但我无法理解这一点，因为总的来说他似乎很喜欢吉姆。听着，如果他的计划是解雇所有参与
in the Sabre store launch, Dundermiflin would have been downsized maybe in the way it was supposed to be all along. True, but I thought Alison made a good point, which is that Robert was kind of like wanting Jim to come work on something that he knew he was never going to approve. Yeah.
赛博商店推出的人员，邓德米夫林本来可能会被缩减规模，也许这正是它一直以来应有的样子。没错，但我认为艾莉森提出了一个很好的观点，那就是罗伯特有点像想让吉姆来从事一项他明知自己永远不会批准的工作。是的。
Not a cool thing to do to a guy you supposedly like. Yeah. Take him away from his wife and newborn baby. It's clear he didn't care about that. Well, we know that already. Now Nellie and Dwight are practicing their presentation in front of Todd Packer and Gabe and Kathy and Jim shows up and he says, Hey, you know what, Dwight, I need presentation in front of Todd Packer and Gabe and Kathy. And Jim shows up and he says, hey, you know what, Dwight, I need to talk to you privately.
对一个你理应喜欢的人来说，这可真不是件酷事。是的。把他从妻子和新生儿身边带走。很显然他并不在乎这一点。好吧，我们已经知道了。现在内莉和德怀特正在托德·帕克、盖布、凯茜面前练习他们的演示，吉姆出现了，他说，嘿，你知道吗，德怀特，我需要和托德·帕克、盖布、凯茜一起练习他们的演示，吉姆出现了，他说，嘿，你知道吗，德怀特，我需要私下跟你谈谈。
This starts Dwight and Packer just pretty much going off on Jim, making fun of him. Well, this scene was bigger. And in the shooting draft, there is a slight nod to how Kathy might feel about Jim these days. Here's how it read. Jim peeks into the room. Jim says, there you are. Dwight says, what are you doing here?
这让德怀特和帕克几乎立刻开始对吉姆大加嘲弄，取笑他。好吧，这个场景本来更大。在拍摄剧本中，有一个微小的暗示，暗示凯茜这些天对吉姆的感觉如何。内容是这样的：吉姆探头进房间。吉姆说，原来你在这儿。德怀特说，你来这儿干什么？
I thought I was done with you. Kathy says, I'm calling security. Dwight lifts a hand to call Kathy off. Dwight says, it's okay, Kathy, I'll allow it. And he turns to Jim and says, you'll have to excuse my new assistant. She hates you. And then he says, now scram, we're rehearsing.
我以为我已经摆脱你了。凯茜说，我叫保安了。德怀特举起一只手制止凯茜。德怀特说，没关系，凯茜，我允许他进来。然后他转向吉姆说，你得原谅我的新助理。她恨死你了。接着他说，快滚吧，我们在排练呢。
Very interesting. So Kathy is the new VP's assistant. Well, this is very interesting, Angela, because Allison H. from Louisville, Kentucky wrote in a second letter about this episode. OK. And Allison said, this is the last time we see Kathy with zero explanation Louisville Kentucky wrote in a second letter about this episode. Okay. And Allison said, this is the last time we see Kathy with zero explanation of what happened
非常有趣。所以凯茜是新副总裁的助理。好吧，这非常有趣，安吉拉，因为来自肯塔基州路易斯维尔的艾莉森·H.写了第二封关于这一集的信。好的。艾莉森说，这是我们最后一次看到凯茜，但对她发生了什么没有任何解释。路易斯维尔的艾莉森写了关于这一集的第二封信。好的。艾莉森说，这是我们最后一次看到凯茜，但对她发生了什么没有任何解释。
to her. Is there a deleted scene or anything in the script that explains her disappearance? Was she fired with packer? I saw a Reddit theory that maybe she was planning to stay in Florida to work at the store, explaining why she was at the meeting when everyone else flew home, and then she got fired, but I don't know if this was ever explicitly addressed. Well, I think the same kind of was. Yeah. Well, if she's the new VP's assistant, when he gets fired, she gets fired. Yeah. Also, in an early outline of the script, it says that Kathy gets fired.
剧本里有没有被删掉的场景或其他东西来解释她的失踪？她是被和帕克一起解雇的吗？我看到一个红迪网（Reddit）的理论说，也许她打算留在佛罗里达在商店工作，这解释了为什么当其他人飞回家时她还在会议上，然后她被解雇了，但我不知道这是否曾被明确提及。好吧，我觉得情况差不多就是这样。是的。好吧，如果她是新副总裁的助理，当他被解雇时，她也就被解雇了。此外，在剧本的早期大纲中，确实写着凯茜被解雇了。
Oh. Mm-hmm. Okay. And also, a lot of people that worked in the Saber Store are all fired. Now, some of them weren't regular cast members, but pretty much Robert California gets rid of everyone. So, oh my gosh. What? If that were true, then Erin would have been fired.
哦。嗯哼。好吧。而且，在赛博商店工作的好多人都被解雇了。现在，他们中有些不是常规演员，但基本上罗伯特·加利福尼亚把所有人都赶走了。所以，哦，天哪。什么？如果那是真的，那么艾琳本也会被解雇。
But she already quit. Right? I don't know. We don't know. She's working for Irene. It would mean that Aaron, Gabe, Kathy, Dwight, Hacker, and Jim were all fired. And Stanley. Oh, yes.
但她已经辞职了。对吧？我不知道。我们不知道。她在为艾琳工作。这意味着艾琳、盖布、凯茜、德怀特、帕克和吉姆全都被解雇了。还有斯坦利。哦，是的。
And Ryan. But Stanley left. Where's Ryan in this meeting? Why is Andy? He left. Remember, he got freaked out. Oh, that's right. And the last episode.
还有瑞安。但斯坦利走了。瑞安在这个会议里在哪儿？为什么安迪——他走了。记不记得，他吓坏了。哦，对了。在上一集。
So, okay. Wow, so basically all the people who abruptly leave this project that they were working on, you would think those would be the people who would get fired from a company because they abandoned post. But no, they saved themselves somehow. And Roberts thinking they were smart enough to leave the sinking ship.
所以，好吧。哇，基本上所有突然离开他们正在从事的项目的人，你都会觉得这些人会因为擅离职守而被公司解雇。但并没有，他们不知怎么地自救了。而罗伯特认为他们足够聪明，懂得离开这艘沉船。
Hmm. Well, we also had a fan catch from Aiden W. and Portland, Oregon, who said, oh my gosh, Dwight cracks a joke about Jim's hair and everyone laughs. And then Gabe tries to high five Kathy, and she totally rejects it. It was a hilarious background choice. So I checked the script because I saw this little beat.
嗯。好吧，我们还收到了来自俄勒冈州波特兰市的艾登·W.的粉丝抓包，他说，哦，天哪，德怀特拿吉姆的头发开玩笑，大家都笑了。然后盖布试图和凯茜击掌，但她完全拒绝了。这是一个搞笑的背景细节。所以我查了剧本，因为我注意到了这个微小的节奏。
It was not scripted. This is what was scripted. Dwight says, quote, what is it? Your hair stylist ran out of messy spray. People laugh obsequiously. Obsequiously. It says that over and over again. Every time Dwight or Packer give an insult, the script says people laugh obstuiciously, obstuiciously. How do you say it? What does this mean? I don't know, I'd have to read it. Obstuiciously. Obstuiciously.
剧本里没有。剧本里写的是这样的：德怀特说，原话是，“怎么了？你的发型师乱喷定型喷雾的用完了吗？”人们谄媚地笑。谄媚地。剧本里一遍又一遍地写着这个词。每次德怀特或帕克进行侮辱，剧本都写着人们谄媚地笑，谄媚地。你怎么读这个词？这是什么意思？我不知道，我得读一下它。谄媚地（obstuiciously）。谄媚地（obstuiciously）。
Yeah, obstuiciously. Do you know what that means? No. I mean Robert Patnik loves obsequiously. It's a very specific adjective, are you googling it? Yeah, I googled it and it means in an obedient or attentive to an excessive degree. Oh, so they're laughing at what their boss says is funny. Not anyone else, only the boss is funny. Yes, it's such a specific direction. And I think I know exactly how to laugh at something
是的，谄媚地。你知道那是什么意思吗？不知道。我的意思是，罗伯特·帕德尼克非常喜欢用“obsequiously”（谄媚地）。这是一个非常具体的形容词，你在用谷歌搜它吗？是的，我谷歌了一下，它的意思是过分顺从或殷勤。哦，所以他们是在笑他们老板觉得好笑的话。不是任何人，只有老板好笑。是的，这是一个非常具体的导演指令。我想我知道该如何对某事发笑，
if I knew what that word meant, but you know, that you have to laugh because you're pleasing your boss. It's the kiss ass laugh. Yes, the kiss ass laugh. Yeah, Robert, you could have just put laugh. The kiss ass laugh. Laugh in a kiss ass laugh. Yeah, Robert, you could have just put laugh. The kiss ass laugh. Laugh in a kiss ass way. But no, the proper way to say that is obsequiously.
如果我知道那个词是什么意思的话，但你知道的，你必须笑，因为你在取悦你的老板。这就是马屁精式的笑。是的，马屁精式的笑。是的，罗伯特，你本来可以直接写“笑”。马屁精式的笑。以马屁精的方式笑。但不对，正确的说法是“obsequiously”。
We also had another fan question from Natasha M in the UK who said, I've been waiting ages to ask this. When Dwight says to Jim, quote, you look like the world's tallest hobbit, was this a nod to Jim's UK counterpart, Tim, played by Martin Freeman, who also played Bilbo Baggins in the Hobbit? Oh. Well, Natasha, I don't know how ever that line was not in the script. I think it was a pitch on the day, because the script had Dwight saying, you should just know that your shadow looks like a sunflower.
我们还收到了来自英国的娜塔莎·M.的另一个粉丝提问，她说，我等了好久才问这个问题。当德怀特对吉姆说，原话是，“你看起来就像世界上最高的霍比特人”时，这是在向吉姆在英国版中的对标角色蒂姆致敬吗？蒂姆由马丁·弗里曼扮演，他还在《霍比特人》中扮演了比尔博·巴金斯？哦。好吧，娜塔莎，我不知道这句台词是怎么回事，它根本不在剧本里。我认为这是当天即兴想出来的，因为剧本里德怀特说的是，“你只需知道你的影子看起来像一朵向日葵。”
Oh, also, Angela, Natasha from the UK would like you to know that since listening to office ladies, she has left her previous employer of 22 years to become a trainee train driver, and she fully qualified July 7th. So Natasha said I'm not sure when this episode will air, but I will potentially be a qualified train driver by then and Natasha knows you love trains.
哦，还有，安吉拉，来自英国的娜塔莎想让你知道，自从听了《办公室淑女》后，她已经辞去了她效力22年的前雇主的工作，成为了一名见习火车司机，并且在7月7日顺利通过了全科考核。所以娜塔莎说，我不确定这一集什么时候播出，但到那时我可能已经是一名合格的火车司机了，而且娜塔莎知道你喜欢火车。
I do, way to go Natasha. Congratulations. I love it. Maybe I'll get to ride on your train someday. Yeah, when we go to the UK. Yeah. I love taking the train. Me too. I just went to another place. Did you see me? Yeah, train. You went to your happy train place. Okay. Well, listen,
我是，干得好，娜塔莎。恭喜。我太喜欢了。也许有一天我能坐上你的火车。是的，当我们去英国的时候。是的。我喜欢坐火车。我也是。我刚才去了另一个地方。你看到我了吗？是的，火车。你去了你的快乐火车地方。好吧。听着，
Jim is going to say, I tried. I tried to tell Dwight what was going to happen. He just made fun of me basically. So I'm out of here. I have a plane to catch catch he leaves. Yes, add Jim to the list of people who bail and don't lose their job. Correct. Well back at Irene's house, Aaron has decided to video chat with Andy to let him know that she's not going to be working for Dunderclund anymore. Yes. Her password is Aaron1234. Irene knows more about all of this technology than Aaron.
吉姆要说了，我试过了。我试图告诉德怀特会发生什么。他基本上只是嘲笑我。所以我离开这儿了。我还有飞机要赶，他离开了。是的，把吉姆加入到那些开溜却没有失去工作的人的名单中。没错。回到艾琳的家里，艾琳决定和安迪视频聊天，让他知道她将不再为邓德村工作了。是的。她的密码是Aaron1234。艾琳对所有这些技术的了解比艾琳还要多。
Yeah, I mean, the scene starts off with them doing this little gag of coming in sideways and then moving the screen and all of this. And they're giggling and yeah, but then when he finds out that she's not coming back, he's pretty upset. You know in a table read version of the script, Jessica calls his cell phone while he's doing this bit with Aaron on the laptop.
是的，我的意思是，场景开始时他们就在做一个小把梗，侧身入镜，然后移动屏幕之类的一切。他们在咯咯笑，是的，但后来当他发现她不回来时，他相当沮丧。你知道在剧本的围读版本中，杰西卡在笔记本电脑上和艾琳做这个片段时给他的手机打电话吗？
Mm-hmm. And he's kind of like annoyed trying to get Jessica off the line. Why Andy? Why Jessica is terrific. I know. She brings out a great side of you. I know. I don't get it. And I guess I would just say you know what Jessica? You dodged a bullet because this man doesn't appreciate you. I know. I don't get it. And I guess I would just say, you know what, Jessica, you dodged a bullet because this man doesn't appreciate you. You don't want to be Mrs. maybe. No, you don't, Angela. That's right. So get rid of Mr. Maybe. So now Jim is on his way to the airport. He's in the car. I mean, he's going. Yeah. He's in one of those passenger vans. And Stanley is in the back. He's kind of slump towards the window. I mean, he's going. Yeah, he's in one of those passenger vans. And Stanley is in the back. He's kind of slump towards the window.
嗯哼。他有点像很烦躁地想把杰西卡打发掉。为什么安迪？为什么杰西卡那么棒？我知道。她能激发你很好的一面。我知道。我不明白。我想我会说，你知道吗，杰西卡，你躲过了一劫，因为这个男人不欣赏你。我知道。我不明白。我想我会说，你知道吗，杰西卡，你躲过了一劫，因为这个男人不欣赏你。你可不想当备胎太太。不，你不想，安吉拉。没错了。所以甩掉这个备胎先生吧。所以现在吉姆在去机场的路上。他在车里。我是说，他正要去。是的。他坐在一辆乘客货车里。斯坦利坐在后面。他有点无精打采地靠向窗户。我是说，他正要去。是的。他坐在一辆乘客货车里。斯坦利坐在后面。他有点无精打采地靠向窗户。
He's grumpy. I mean, he doesn't want to be scrant in Stanley. He wants to be Florida Stanley. But Jim's talking to Pam on the phone. And Pam is kind of saying, Jim, you have to tell Dwight. You have to. And Jim's insisting that he tried. And she's like, did you though?
他很暴躁。我是说，他不想当斯克兰顿的斯坦利。他想当佛罗里达的斯坦利。但吉姆在电话里跟帕姆说话。帕姆有点在说，吉姆，你得告诉德怀特。你必须这么做。吉姆坚称他试过了。然后她说，你真的试了吗？
Did you try? And I think, you know, this is how, I guess it does track. I mean, how hard did Jim try to get Kathy out of his hotel room? And how hard did he try to tell Dwight this news? I mean, Jim's definition of try is pretty weak. You know, it was interesting during the scene. I couldn't help but hear you a little bit,
你试过吗？我想，你知道，这就是，我想这确实说得通。我是说，吉姆为了让凯茜离开他的酒店房间到底有多努力？他告诉德怀特这个消息到底有多努力？我是说，吉姆对“尝试”的定义实在是太弱了。你知道，在这一场戏中很有趣，我不禁听到你讲了一点，
uh-huh, because one of the things you're really good at is sort of understanding how people talk to one another. And so when Pam's like, no, wait, what exactly did Robert say he's going to do? And Jim's like, I don't know, maybe like give Dwight a talking to, and Pam very clearly says, Robert doesn't talk like that.ight a talking to and Pam very clearly says, Robert doesn't talk like that.
嗯哼，因为你真的很擅长的一件事就是理解人们是如何互相交谈的。所以当帕姆说，不，等等，罗伯特到底说过他要做什么？吉姆说，我不知道，也许像给德怀特谈一谈，帕姆非常清楚地说，罗伯特才不那样说话呢。他要解雇他。我觉得有时候珍娜，我们会遇到某个人，我会说，哦，是的，而你会说，不，不，不，实际情况是这样的，然后我就想，哦，糟糕。我不知道这是否完全正确，但我认为这是个赞美。我知道这是个赞美。我觉得你很擅长透过表象看本质，看到真正发生的事情。好吧，吉姆最终向帕姆保证，
He's going to fire him. And I feel like sometimes Jenna, like, we'll meet someone and I'll be like, oh yeah, and you're like, no, no, no, this is what's happening. And I'm like, oh crap. I don't know if that's totally true, but I think that's a compliment. I know it is a compliment. I think you're good at cutting through the BS and seeing what's really happening. Well, Jim is gonna ultimately promise Pam,
好吧，我去告诉德怀特。由此开始了一件我觉得非常奇怪的事情。我待会儿再谈。什么？我待会儿再谈。哦，没关系。等我们到了那儿我再提。哦，好吧。基本上，好吧，我还是直说吧，因为现在我很好奇。我知道，你又不想等。好吧，我不想让你到那儿之后——哦，好吧。基本上，好吧，我还是直说吧，因为现在我很好奇。我知道，你又不想等。好吧，我不想让你不得不去猜。斯坦利不能去机场。为什么斯坦利也要等去机场？因为他们坐在同一辆乘客货车里。他们坐在同一辆乘客货车里。
okay, I'll tell Dwight. And thus begins something that I found very odd. I'll talk about it later. What? I'll talk about it later. Oh, it's okay. I'll bring it up when we get there. Oh, okay.
这一切是怎么发展的？吉姆要带着车里的斯坦利把整辆客运货车调头。斯坦利才不想离开佛罗里达呢。你觉得他会在乎绕点路吗？好吧，好吧，我接受这个解释。谢谢你。他可能去了酒店酒吧正在喝鸡尾酒呢。你说得对。回到斯克兰顿，托比和达瑞尔现在真的是大动干戈了。
Basically, okay, I'll just say it, but because now I'm curious. I know and you don't wanna wait. Okay, I don't want you when we get there. Oh, okay. Basically, okay, I'll just say it, but because now I'm curious. I know, and you don't want to wait. Okay, I don't want you to have to guess. Stanley can't go to the airport. Why does Stanley wait to go to the airport, too? Because they're in the same passenger van. They're in the same passenger van.
他们为了赢得凯文的饼干生意正在超级卖力地拉票。整个办公区的人都坐在周围看着。他们大声喊着各种他们必须要做的事情。整个工作日都为这停下来了。是的，他们就像是，你必须亲吻梅雷迪思。你必须，还有其他所有那些事情是什么？他们必须为他们唱首歌。是的。
How does this all go down? Jim's gonna turn around the whole passenger van with Stanley in it. Stanley doesn't want to leave Florida. Do you think he cares if he takes a detour? Okay, all right, I'll buy that. Thank you. You probably went to the hotel bar and is having a cocktail. You're right. Back in Scranton, Toby and Darryl are really going at it now.
关于那首歌，我有一个惊人的消息。你猜它花了我多少钱？4美元。0美元。哦，零。它是公共版权的。0.00美元。0.00美元。哦，零。它是公共版权的。我们白白得到了它。好吧，这里什么也没有解决。
They're campaigning super hard to win Kevin's cookie business. And the whole bullpen is just sitting around watching. They're shouting out different things they have to do. The whole workday has stopped for this. Yeah, they're like, you have to kiss Meredith. You have to, what are all the other things? They have to sing a song for them. Yes.
他还没选出赢家，他们威胁说，除非他透露自己准备订购三位数的数量，否则他们就不再为争取他的生意而竞争了。是的。好吧，还记得我们的编剧罗伯特是怎么跟我说的吗，在他的最初大纲里有这样一条帕姆和凯文的故事线。它的高潮将是这样的：帕姆开始担心凯文被占了便宜。好吧，他根本不需要买一百盒饼干。
I've got some surprising news about that song. Guess how much it cost us? $4. $0. Oh, zero. It was public domain..00. $0.00. Oh, zero. It was public domain. We got it for nothing. Well, nothing is really resolved here.
关于那首歌我有一个惊人的消息。猜猜我们花了两多少钱？4美元。0美元。哦，零。它是公有领域的。..00。0.00美元。哦，零。它是公有领域的。我们没花一分钱就得到了它。好吧，这里其实什么问题都没有解决。
He hasn't picked a winner, and they threatened to stop competing for his business until he reveals he's prepared to order triple digits. Yeah. Well, remember how our writer Robert told me there was this Pam Kevin's storyline in his original outline. It would have culminated with this. Pam becomes concerned that Kevin is being taken advantage of. Okay, that he really doesn't need to buy a hundred boxes of cookies.
他还没选出赢家，而他们威胁说，在他透露自己准备订购三位数数量的产品之前，将停止竞争他的业务。是的。嗯，还记得我们的编剧罗伯特告诉我，在他的原始大纲中有一个帕姆和凯文的故事线吗？它本该以这个达到高潮：帕姆开始担心凯文被占了便宜。好吧，担心他其实根本不需要买一百盒饼干。
So she decides she will not buy her two boxes of thin mints, which is equally hard for her if Kevin doesn't buy his 100 boxes. She's like, Kevin, come on. We're going to make this pack together. And that solidarity gives Kevin the strength to not buy any cookies at all. Oh, wow. So the episode would have ended with Kevin buying nothing. Yeah, Kevin would have made the choice that he doesn't need a hundred boxes of cookies, not because he loses the favor of Darryl and Toby. Kind of like it. I know.
所以她决定不买她那两盒薄荷糖了，如果凯文不买那100盒糖，这对她来说同样很难。她对凯文说，拜托，凯文。我们要一起共进退。这种团结让凯文有了不买任何饼干的力量。哦，哇。所以这一集本该以凯文什么都不买而结束。是啊，凯文会做出不需要一百盒饼干的选择，不是因为他失去了达里尔和托比的欢心。我有点喜欢这个结局。我也是。
And what Robert said he really liked is that it was just as hard for Pam to give up her two boxes of thinnments as it was for Kevin to give up a hundred boxes of cookies. Well, back at Saber, Jim rushes in to tell Dwight about Robert's plan, but Dwight doesn't believe him. No, he says nothing is going to stop him, which is the mark of a great man, Dundermiflin the farm mose, they're in his rear-view mirror. He has a date with Destiny.
罗伯特说他真的很喜欢这一点，因为帕姆放弃两盒薄荷糖和凯文放弃一百盒饼干对他们来说一样艰难。好了，镜头转回圣别公司，吉姆冲进去告诉德怀特关于罗伯特的计划，但德怀特不相信他。不，他说没有什么能阻止他，这是一个伟大之人的标志，邓德米夫林的农场莫斯，都在他的后视镜里了。他与命运有个约会。
We had a fan question about this, Angela. From Amber Leighby and Florida, who said, I have never understood how Dwight is so ready to leave behind Scranton. He once said one of his life goals was to die in his desk chair at Dunder Mifflin. Yeah. Also his beat farm, which has been passed down in his family for generations. He's devoted so much time to it.
安吉拉，我们有一个关于这的粉丝问题。来自佛罗里达州的琥珀·莉比，她说，我一直不明白德怀特怎么能这么轻易地抛弃斯克兰顿。他曾说过他的人生目标之一就是在邓德米夫林的办公椅上去世。对。还有他的黑醋栗农场，那是他家族世世代代传下来的。他为之倾注了那么多时间。
He loves living out there. It seems like a lot for him to leave behind. Discuss. Well, Amber Lee, I think this is a great question, and I really hear what you mean. All I can think of is that Dwight has yearned for this title, some kind of title. It's given him a sense of confidence, self-worth. It's been this thing he's been working towards for so long. And I think in the moment, it's blurred some of the things
他喜欢住在那里。对他来说，要抛弃这一切似乎很难。大家讨论一下吧。嗯，琥珀·莉，我觉得这是一个很好的问题，我真的很能理解你的意思。我能想到的就是，德怀特一直渴望得到这个头衔，某种头衔。这给了他一种自信和自我价值感。这是他长期以来一直为之努力的事情。我想在那个时刻，它模糊了一些事情，
that really mean a lot to him because he's wanted it for so long, this title, this VP or branch manager, whatever it was, it's a title at this company. Yeah, I think that his ambition is blinding him here. Yeah. Nothing Jim says works. So he's decided to just tackle Dwight. Yeah, just tackle him to the ground.
那些对真正对他意义重大的事，因为他太渴望得到这个头衔了，不管是副总裁还是分公司经理，总之是这家公司的头衔。对，我觉得他的野心在这里蒙蔽了他的双眼。是的。吉姆说的什么都不管用。所以他决定直接扑倒德怀特。对，直接把他扑倒在地。
And look all of a sudden who has pain in his appendix stitches. Yes, mm-hmm. Didn't seem to bother him when he was going after the bed bugs. Nope, he could dive into a bed and roll around in some sheets. But when he got tackled, he was like, oh my Bandits. Yeah. Well, I think Dwight was faking a little bit
你看，怎么突然间他就得了阑尾炎缝针了。是的，嗯哼。当他去对付臭虫时，这似乎并没有困扰他。没错，他可以跳进床铺，在床单里打滚。但当他被扑倒时，他就像是，哦，我的斑点狗。好吧，我觉得德怀特有点在装病，
because he's going to rev up and he's gonna try to charge Jim. He's gonna go up the wall a little bit and then he falls. I thought it was so funny when he started doing his little foot back and forth motion on the carpet Jim was like I know what you're doing. Yeah, it doesn't work This is when they reminded me of two brothers that just know each other so well. Oh, yeah, that's such a good observation So we got a lot of fan mail about this fight people wanted to know if they were just playing around or if it was choreographed
因为他要振作起来，试图冲向吉姆。他会稍微往墙上爬一下，然后就摔倒了。我觉得当他在地毯上开始做那种前后蹬腿的动作时太搞笑了，吉姆就说我知道你在干什么。对，不管用。这让我想起了两个彼此太了解的兄弟。哦，是的，这个观察太棒了。所以我们收到了很多关于这场打斗的粉丝邮件，大家想知道他们是在胡闹还是经过编排的，
and I reached out to Steve Burgess. And he reminded me that this was actually the action here was meticulously scripted and that it was all worked out with our stunt coordinator Brett Jones. It was all choreographed. He said for some of the close-up shots, we had fall pads on the ground and then they would pull them out for the wider shots. But they did such a great job of making it look like it was just happening in the moment.
我联系了史蒂夫·伯吉斯。他提醒我，其实这里的动作是经过精心编写的，而且是和我们的特技协调员布雷特·琼斯一起商量确定的。全部都是编排好的。他说，对于一些特写镜头，我们在地上铺了防摔垫，然后拍远景时会把它们撤走。但他们把这拍得就像是即兴发生的一样，做得太棒了。
Robert Padnik said this moment between Jim and Dwight was one of the highlights for him of the episode. Well I went to the script and I pulled out all of the stage directions that Robert wrote and they really executed them perfectly. We should read them, because they're so detailed. I know, okay, so here are all of the scripted actions. It starts with this. Jim has dragged Dwight away from the conference room
罗伯特·帕德尼克说，吉姆和德怀特之间的这一幕是这一集中对他而言的亮点之一。我翻看了剧本，挑出了罗伯特写的所有舞台指示，他们真的完美地执行了这些指示。我们应该读一读，因为它们太详细了。我知道，好吧，以下是所有的剧本动作。开始是这样的。吉姆把德怀特从会议室拉了出来，
into another room. Dwight clings to the wall as Jim pulls on him. Jim puts his hand over Dwight's mouth to stop him from yelling after a moment he pulls away. Dwight starts kicking at Jim's crotch. Jim tugs on him harder. Now I don't remember that part. Now we get to the part where he's supposed to act like a bull and it says still doubled over. Dwight charges Jim like a bull. Dwight starts scuffing his foot on the floor, then he starts running in place. Dwight charges at Jim, then veers at the last second. He tries to run up the wall
带到另一个房间。吉姆拉着德怀特时，德怀特紧紧抓住墙壁。吉姆把手捂在德怀特嘴上，阻止他大喊大叫，过了一会儿他把手拿开。德怀特开始踢吉姆的裆部。吉姆更用力地拉他。现在我不记得那一部分了。接下来是我们来到他应该表现得像一头公牛的部分，上面写着依然弯着腰。德怀特像公牛一样冲向吉姆。德怀特开始在地板上蹭脚，然后开始原地跑步。德怀特冲向吉姆，然后在最后一秒转向。他试图往墙上跑，
and over Jim, but crashes to the ground. It continues, guys. I think you're done there. No. It says Dwight and Jim both tired, continue to tussle. Dwight is arduously dragging Jim. He stops exhausted. That says Dwight pokes a finger into Jim's kidney. I don't think that would happen. Maybe it did though. And we cut it down. Maybe this was a bigger fight for them. It says that Dwight lifts Jim up, but can only get him a few inches off the ground. I liked that detail. That was funny.
越过吉姆，却重重摔在地上。还没完呢，各位。我觉得你们到那儿就结束了吧。没有。上面写着，德怀特和吉姆都很累，继续纠缠在一起。德怀特费力地拖着吉姆。他停下来，筋疲力尽。上面写着德怀特用手指戳了吉姆的肾。我觉得那不会发生。不过也许发生了呢。然后我们把它剪掉了。也许对他们来说这是一场更大规模的打斗。上面写着德怀特把吉姆举起来，但只能把他举离地面几英寸。我喜欢这个细节。太搞笑了。
He slams him down. By the way, I loved it when Jim grabbed the plant. That's not in the direction, but it cracked me up. Yeah. Basically, it ends with them both on the ground and Dwight rolling over and getting up with a groan, it says. Jim stays on the ground. He's done. He tried. Now that is trying. Okay, Pam. Okay. I just want to say, now you can say you He tried. Now that is trying. Okay, Pam. Okay. I just want to say now you can say you've tried. Well, while all of this was going on, there would have been a scene inside the boardroom. It was in the shooting draft. We did shoot it. It's in deleted scenes. And Todd Packer is going to try to bond with Robert California. Oh, yeah, because they're all in there. And they're like, where's Dwight?
他把他重重摔在地上。顺便说一句，我太喜欢吉姆抓住那盆植物的时候了。剧本里没有这个指示，但把我逗乐了。对。基本上，结局是两人都倒在地上，德怀特呻吟着翻身爬起来，上面写着。吉姆留在地上。他累瘫了。他尽力了。这才是真正的尽力。好吧，帕姆。好吧。我只想说，现在你可以说你 他尽力了。这才是真正的尽力。好吧，帕姆。好吧。我只想说，现在你可以说你已经尽力了。好吧，所有这一切发生的同时，董事会内部本该有一场戏。它在拍摄剧本里。我们确实拍了。它在删减片段里。托德·帕克试图跟罗伯特·卡利福尼亚套近乎。哦，对，因为他们都在里面。他们就在想，德怀特去哪儿了？
Yeah, that's going on. Why aren't we starting this? Yeah. Well, Jenna, you might have a soulmate in Robert California because here's what happened. The shooting draft read, the board has gathered. The current slide reads, what's in store? Robert sits, contentedly awaiting what's to come. Packer sidles up next to him. Packer says, Amped for Thrones. Off of Robert's Blink look,
对，正在发生这事。我们为什么还不开始？对，詹娜，你在罗伯特·卡利福尼亚身上可能找到了灵魂伴侣，因为事情是这样的。拍摄剧本上写着，董事会已经集合。当前的幻灯片写着，有什么惊喜？罗伯特坐着，心满意足地等待着接下来的事情。帕克悄悄走到他旁边。帕克说，对权力的游戏很兴奋吗？面对罗伯特茫然的表情，
Packer says, Game of Thrones. There's a long beat. Packer says, it's a show on HBO. Robert says, oh no. Packer slinks away. Oh, Robert, Lick Jenna, there's someone else. This not as into sort of fantasy stuff. I know, maybe he would have loved the edge. I think he would have actually. I think he really would have loved the edge. I think he would have actually. I think he really would have. As it turns out, Packer is going to take over the role of VP.
帕克说，权力的游戏。沉默了一拍。帕克说，这是HBO的一个节目。罗伯特说，哦，不。帕克灰溜溜地走开了。哦，罗伯特，不像詹娜，还有别人。不那么喜欢那种奇幻题材的东西。我知道，也许他会喜欢边缘世界。我觉得他其实会喜欢的。我觉得他真的很喜欢边缘世界。我觉得他其实会。事实证明，帕克将接任副总裁一职。
He's going to do the presentation with Nelly. Yeah, he knows it forwards and backwards and doggie style. He's ready to go. And as promised, Robert is going to tank it and fire Packer. Yeah. Justice Dwight is walking in the door. He hears this and he realizes Jim was right. Jim really was trying to save his job. Yeah. My second favorite line of this episode happened in this scene. Nelly says, Whatever you do, do not blame Todd Packer. It is not his fault. Blame his upbringing, his parents, the society that would mold this idiotic creature. Fire the employee.
他将和内莉一起做演讲。对，他对流程倒背如流、驾轻就熟。他准备好了。正如承诺的那样，罗伯特会搞砸这一切并解雇帕克。是的。正当德怀特走进门时。他听到了这话，意识到吉姆是对的。吉姆真的是在救他的工作。对。这一集中我第二喜欢的台词就出现在这个场景里。内莉说，无论你做什么，千万不要责怪托德·帕克。这不是他的错误。要怪就怪他的成长经历、他的父母、这个塑造出这个弱智生物的社会。开除这个员工。
Yes, but not the man. You may not cancel his soul. And then Robert California says that was never on the table. He's cracked me up. Dwight's going to leave the conference room and he's going to have a nice moment with Jim. He's going to realize Jim really was being his friend. It's a really sweet kind of moment and hallway offers Jim his hand to help him up up the ground. Jim hasn't moved.
是的，但不要开除这个人。你不能否定他的灵魂。然后罗伯特·卡利福尼亚说，这从来不在讨论范围之内。他把我逗乐了。德怀特要离开会议室了，他和吉姆会有一个美好的时刻。他会意识到吉姆确实在当他的朋友。这是一个非常温馨的时刻，在走廊里，他向吉姆伸出援手，帮他从地上拉起来。吉姆没有动。
He's very tired. I saw a few people write in and say they wondered if this was a turning point for Jim and Dwight. Yeah, that's true. There were people who remembered what Great Daniel said about how Jim and Dwight were never to become friends, but they thought there have been a couple of nods in the last few episodes them having their desserts in Florida and then this moment in Florida. Yep. Don't worry, they'll fight again. Well now the Saber, Florida crew are gonna arrive back to Scranton.
他太累了。我看到几个人留言说，他们想知道这是否是吉姆和德怀特关系的转折点。对，没错。有些人记得大卫·雷纳说过吉姆和德怀特绝不会成为朋友，但他们认为过去几集里有一些暗示，比如他们在佛罗里达吃甜点，然后就是佛罗里达的这个时刻。没错。别担心，他们还会打架的。现在，圣别公司的佛罗里达团队要回到斯克兰顿了。
They walk in Stanley, Dwight, Jim. Everyone's excited to see them. Pam seems surprised. She's like, hey stranger, then they make out in front of everyone. I just wrote awkward, what the hell is happening? Is this Jim's first time seeing Pam? Had they not been texting? She seemed surprised.
他们走了进来，斯坦利、德怀特、吉姆。每个人都很高兴看到他们。帕姆看起来很惊讶。她说，嘿，陌生人，然后他们在所有人面前热吻。我当时只写了，尴尬，这到底是怎么回事？这是吉姆第一次见到帕姆吗？他们之前没发过短信吗？她看起来很惊讶。
Now they're making out what the heck. Well, Angela, Meela P. from Houston, Texas was also confused and wondered, Pam is so shocked to see Jim. How is it possible that a wife doesn't know her husband is coming back home after being gone for a while? Also, Savannah M from Salt Lake City, Utah, said, why did the Florida team come back to the office
现在他们居然在热吻，搞什么鬼。嗯，安吉拉，来自德克萨斯州休斯顿的米拉·P也很困惑，想知道，帕姆看到吉姆竟然这么震惊。一个妻子怎么可能不知道自己的丈夫离开一段时间后要回家了呢？还有来自犹他州盐湖城的萨凡纳·M说，为什么佛罗里达团队要回办公室，
rather than go home? It seems weird to bring all their luggage to the office rather than have the rest of the day off. And Anna L. from Granada, Spain, who is now living in Quark, Ireland, said, how many hours did this day have? They started playing golf, had a meeting about Saber, Dwight and Jim got in a fight,
而不是直接回家？把所有的行李都带到办公室，而不是剩下的一天都放假，这看起来很奇怪。还有来自西班牙格拉纳达、现在住在爱尔兰科克的安娜·L说，这一天到底有多少个小时？他们先是去打高尔夫，开了关于圣别的会，德怀特和吉姆打了一架，
and still took a flight from Tallahassee to Scranton to arrive back at the office before 5 p.m. That's a good point. And by the way, I want to say, Anna, I looked it up, arrive back at the office before 5pm. That's a good point. And by the way, I want to say, Anna, I looked it up and it isn't almost 4 hour flight from Tallahassee to Scrin. This is what I wrote down, Angela. How is Jim arriving back with Stanley?
竟然还坐了从塔拉哈西到斯克兰顿的航班，在下午5点前赶回了办公室。这倒是个好点子。顺便说一句，安娜，我查过了，下午5点前赶回办公室。这倒是个好点子。顺便说一句，安娜，我查过了，从塔拉哈西飞到斯克兰顿几乎需要4个小时的飞行时间。这是我记下的，安吉拉。吉姆怎么会和斯坦利一起回来？
Weren't they on an earlier flight? Why wouldn't Stanley have just flown on his original flight? Also Dwight didn't even have a plane ticket home because he thought he was staying in Florida. How did the three of them all wind up on the same flight out of Florida and make it back by 5pm? And also, wouldn't Pam pick him up at the airport? Or wouldn't she be like, honey, you were supposed to come home three hours ago on that other flight that you told me you were coming home on?
他们不是坐的早一点的航班吗？为什么斯坦利不坐他原本的航班？而且德怀特甚至都没有回程的机票，因为他以为自己要留在佛罗里达。他们三个人怎么最后都坐上了同一趟离开佛罗里达的航班，并且在下午5点前赶回来的？而且，帕姆难道不应该去机场接他吗？或者她难道不会说，亲爱的，你本该在三小时前坐你告诉我你要回来的那个航班回家的吗？
No, she's like, hey, stranger. Well, you know, it had been a long time since Jim and Pam had been scripted to do a kiss. Oh, yeah. And for whatever reason, John and I, we just kept breaking. I think it was also because Ed was like right over our shoulder. Andy is right there. He's supposed to, I guess, take in the moment, get inspired to go get Aaron, but it's so awkward because
不，她是说，嘿，陌生人。嗯，你知道的，吉姆和帕姆已经很久没有按剧本拍过吻戏了。哦，对。不管出于什么原因，乔恩和我，我们总是频频笑场。我想这也是因为爱德就在我们的肩膀后面。安迪就在那儿。我想他本该体会那一刻，激发去找艾瑞克的灵感，但这一切太尴尬了，因为
he's just a little head bobbing behind you. Well, there's a bunch of bloopers of that moment. I'll tell you that. Andy's now going to have this talking head where he says, I'm going to Florida, you know, going to go get Aaron. It's crazy, right? And he's trying to shut off his computer, but he has all these tabs open and it's moving slowly. Yeah. What the hell's happening?
他就在你身后晃着脑袋。好吧，那个时刻有很多NG镜头。我只能告诉你这些。安迪接下来会有一个对着镜头的独白，他说，我要去佛罗里达，你知道的，去把艾瑞克追回来。太疯狂了，对吧？他试图关闭电脑，但他打开了所有的标签页，电脑运行得很慢。对。这到底是怎么回事？
He has a ring. He's ready to propose to Jessica. Mm-hmm. A dimondless ring. Yeah, from his family. He has a setting ready to go. Exactly. Jessica, we're sorry. Yeah, sorry. He's off to go. Exactly. Jessica, we're sorry.
他有一枚戒指。他准备向杰西卡求婚。嗯。一枚没有钻石的戒指。对，来自他的家族。他连镶嵌底座都准备好了。没错。杰西卡，对不起了。对，抱歉。他要出发了。没错。杰西卡，对不起了。
Yeah, sorry, he's off to Florida. There was an alternate ending to this episode. Oh yeah, it's in the shooting draft. It's a hilarious tag. I kind of felt like we should read it. Oh, okay. So it's between Phyllis and Stanley. And Jenna, you read Phyllis and I'll read Stanley.
对，抱歉，他要去佛罗里达了。这一集还有一个结局备选。哦，对，它在拍摄剧本里。这是一个非常搞笑的片尾彩蛋。我觉得我们应该读一下。哦，好吧。所以这是菲莉丝和斯坦利之间的对手戏。詹娜，你读菲莉丝的台词，我读斯坦利。
Okay. The script read, Interior Stanley's desk clump, morning. Phyllis unplugs and takes Kathy's mouse from her desk. Phyllis starts the scene. I'll take this. Kathy's not here anymore. Phyllis looks at Stanley's desk.
好的。剧本写着，内景，斯坦利的办公桌区，早晨。菲莉丝拔掉并拿走了凯西桌上的鼠标。菲莉丝开始演。这个我拿走了。凯西不在了。菲莉丝看着斯坦利的桌子。
What's with the stuff? Well, I realize Florida isn't just a state Phyllis, at Stanley's desk. What's with the stuff? Well, I realize Florida isn't just a state Phyllis, it's a state of mind. Look at this. Stanley points to a bottle of sand. Is that cocaine? It's my beach. Stanley points to a bottle of water. This is my ocean.
这些东西是怎么回事？好吧，我意识到佛罗里达不仅仅是一个州，菲莉丝，站在斯坦利的桌子旁。这些东西是怎么回事？好吧，我意识到佛罗里达不仅仅是一个州，菲莉丝，它是一种心态。你看这个。斯坦利指着一瓶沙子。那是可卡因吗？这是我的海滩。斯坦利指着一瓶水。这是我的海洋。
Stanley picks up a flashlight and points it at his face. Stanley continues. And this is my son. Stanley spritzes some suntan lotion spray in the air, he sniffs the air, shuts his eyes, and starts softly moaning, a small smile on his face. Stanley? Stanley? He doesn't respond. This would cut to a Stanley talking head where he would say, well, I just came back from Paradise, which felt like a dream. And now I feel like I woke up and I'm in hell. How the f*** are you?
斯坦利拿起一个手电筒，照向自己的脸。斯坦利继续。这是我的太阳。斯坦利在空中喷了一些防晒喷雾，他嗅了嗅空气，闭上眼睛，开始轻声呻吟，脸上带着一丝微笑。斯坦利？斯坦利？他没有反应。这里会切到一个斯坦利的独白，他说，好吧，我刚刚从天堂回来，那感觉就像一场梦。现在我觉得自己醒了，却身处地狱。你好个鬼啊！
Ha ha ha ha ha. End of episode. End of episode. Oh, thank you to Steve Burgess and Robert Padnick and also to Phil Shea for helping us fill out this episode. And thanks to you guys for sending in your questions and comments. We'll see you next week. See you then! Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jennifer Fisher, and Angela Kinsey.
哈哈哈哈哈哈。剧集结束。剧集结束。哦，感谢史蒂夫·伯吉斯和罗伯特·帕德尼克，还要感谢菲尔·希a帮助我们完善了这一集。也感谢大家发来你们的问题和评论。我们下周见。回头见！感谢收听办公室女士播客。办公室女士由Earwolf、詹妮弗·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。
Our senior producer is Cassie Jirkins. Our in-studio engineer is Sam Keeper. Our editing and mixing engineer is Jordan Duffy, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbaco. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的资深制作人是卡西·吉尔金斯。我们的录音室工程师是萨姆·基珀。我们的剪辑和混音工程师是乔丹·达菲，我们的助理制作人是艾因斯利·巴巴科。我们的主题曲是克里·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。您好，本集暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。